Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
So, bin ich am Start. Irgendwie hat Twitch keine Ankündigung verschickt, kann das sein? Ihr seid bestimmt alle über Twitter da, oder? Oder ist jemand über Twitch direkt da?
Lullulullulullulululululu. Easy. Über Twitch? Okay!
Wundert mich! Weil ich hatte den Stream bestimmt 3-4 Minuten laufen. Echt? Okay, seid über Twitch da? Aha!
Weil ich hatte den Stream irgendwie schon 3-4 Minuten laufen und das war die ganze Zeit bei 0 Zuschauern,
Irgendwie, irgendwie verschickt Twitch nix und ich hab's noch mal auf Twitter gepostet und weiß es nicht.
Progas?
Doch ging, ok.
Also, was wir heute machen, nichts großartiges.
Und zwar, ich zeig euch das mal. Wir machen erst mal kurz Visual Studio auf.
Wir brauchen den ordentlichen Titel, der Titel ist viel zu seriös.
Wir machen, wir machen irgendwas anderes. Der Titel ist viel zu seriös.
Seid mal bitte kreativ, was könnt ihr denn für einen schönen Titel nehmen?
Danach mach ich auch die Kirby Musik aus und zeig euch, was wir machen.
Also ich mein, steht ja schon im Titel, was wir machen, so prinzipiell.
Irgendwas, irgendwas, was zu Twitch passt, Omega Progas oder irgendwie sowas.
Hat ihr mal irgendeine chlorreiche Idee?
Ich seh, ihr seid genauso unkreativ wie ich, was das anbelangt.
Progas, Proga, keine Ahnung, ich bin gerade echt heute nicht besonders kreativ.
Nicht nur nicht kreativ, sondern kurz vor verrecken.
So, also, was kann man als schönen Titel machen für den Stream?
Was kann man als schönen Titel machen?
Slavon Progas macht irgendwie, ja ich mach das sogar kostenlos, eigentlich total bescheuert.
Aber ich mein, er schwimmt ja nicht gerade eben Geld.
Und außer dem Magischen, da kann man was umsonst machen.
Wir bashen Twitch, nee, das ist, das ist.
Ein kleiner Progas möchte aus dem Bälle-Paradies abgeholt werden.
Was haltet ihr davon?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, der Progas.
Ich bin echt...
Ich bin heute echt nicht sonderlich kreativ. Und ich sag ja immer, Programmieren ist eine kreative Arbeit, ja.
Aber das krieg ich schon noch hin.
Also, Progas.
Hab gehofft, dass du streamst, als ich auf Twitter gelesen hab. Ja, Beat, ich muss euch ja ehrlich sagen, ich hab ja auch, also einer der Gründe, warum ich gesagt hab, ey, ich mach dir das, ist ja gerade, dass ich streamen kann.
Das ist ja gerade, das ist auch der Grund, also alle der Hauptgründe, warum ich gesagt hab, wir machen das.
Und er wollte ja eigentlich, ich zeig's euch gleich.
Wir machen Progas bis zum Unfall.
Wir schreiben bis mit 2S, dann sind die ganzen Twilight-Leute getriggert.
Ja, 3x Progas.
Genau, 3x 280 TI als Bezahlung. Da fällt mir echt nichts anderes mehr ein, als easy.
So. Also, was wir heute machen?
Ich hab mir so ungefähr schon überlegt, wie das Ganze aussehen soll.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob Twitch jetzt den Titel ändert gleich noch.
Also, was wir heute machen? Ich hab auf Twitter gelesen, dass der gute Hardware-Rat ein Skript, das er weiß nicht so genau, was er da schreibt.
Das ist viel zu unsophisticated, was er da will. Das ist langweilig, wir müssen da schon ein bisschen die Messlatte oben drücken.
Also, er schreibt hier, er braucht ein Skript, das folgendes kann.
Windows-Key aus einem Nass holen aus einer Textdatei, der oberste Key.
Aktivierung mit dem Key durchführen und wenn erfolgreich Key löschen. Jemand plant davon.
Ich mein, das könnten wir machen, bis auf den Zugriff auf den Windows-Share, wo ich keine Ahnung hätte, wie ich das gescheit mit.NET oder PowerShell mache.
Hier sind das wahrscheinlich 15 Zeilen. Das ist allerdings viel zu billig für uns.
Das heißt, ich hab mir gedacht, was könnte man machen, was ihm auch was bringt.
Ich mein, es bringt ja nichts, das alles komplizierter zu machen, als es irgendwie sein muss.
Nur, dass wir uns hier dran aufgeheimen können. Das ist ja nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache irgendwie.
Übrigens, mein DirectX Gift-Renderding ist fast fertig. Jetzt können wir auch die Tare fertig machen.
Genau, deswegen hab ich gedacht, wir machen das folgendermaßen.
Wieso ist da ein Chrome unten blau? Weil es kein Chrome ist, sondern ein Chromium.
Chromium, beste. Ich kann dir gar nicht mehr genau erklären, warum es ein Chromium ist.
Weil Chromium, ich weiß es nicht. Weil ich mir gedacht hab, ich install...
Ja, Chrome haben wir ja auch installiert. Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir hier zu wenig Web-Browser irgendwie am Start.
Oh nee, Vivaldi hab ich nicht mehr installiert. Aber prinzipiell haben wir gerade mal vier Browser auf. Also da geht ja eigentlich schon noch ein bisschen was.
So, also und was ich mir gedacht hab, was wir machen, ist, wie gesagt, es muss ihm ja auch was bringen.
Es kann ja nicht einfach komplett sinnlos kompliziert sein, nur weil wir das jetzt nicht machen.
Also ich hab mir gedacht, wir machen das folgendes, da hier unten irgendwie, was auch immer, wer hier unten rumspammt.
Weiß ich nicht, dass schon einer was gemacht hat. KMS-Server, na KMS-Server ist ja nur eindeutig zu naheliegend.
So, und ich hab mir gedacht, wir machen das folgendermaßen.
Er braucht dazu allerdings, und ich denk mal, dass er das hat, weil ich meine, hat er geschrieben, vom Nass holen.
Er braucht dazu allerdings eine zweite Kiste neben dem Rechner, den er installieren will.
Und wir werden das folgendermaßen machen. Also ich hab mir das so überlegt. Also fangen wir mal anders an.
Die Billig-Variante wäre wirklich so, wie er das schreibt. Also sprich, man macht ein Programm und eine Settings-Datei.
In der Settings-Datei steht drin, Adresse vom Nass, Username fürs Nass, Passwort fürs Nass, Fahrt zur Datei, oder aber auch noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwas so.
Das müsste in der Settings-Datei drinstehen, dabei ist ein Programm, das ziehst du ja auf jeden Fall.
Führst auf dem jeweiligen Rechner aus, das macht nichts anderes, wie zum Nass ich connecten, die Key-Datei ziehen, Key löschen, Nass-Datei wieder hinschieben und Windows aktivieren.
Oder halt, man könnte sie in die Installation einbauen oder sowas, was auch immer.
Naja, das wäre die Billig-Variante. Ich hab mir gedacht, wir machen das folgendermaßen.
Ein bisschen schöner, dass er auch sehen kann, wie viel Keys er in der Woche verbraucht oder sowas.
Letztendlich hat man die Sachen dadurch, dass man die Keys quasi löscht und sich einen Zeitstempel holen kann, eh schon irgendwo zur Hand.
Also wir machen ein bisschen mehr drum herum. Und ich hab mir gedacht, dass es richtig simpel wird für ihn.
Splitten wir das auf. Und zwar, jetzt machen wir mal eine krasse Paint-Skills. Kommen wir jetzt mal an den Start.
Warte mal, ich mach mal kurz Kirby aus. Kirby geht mir auf den Sack.
24-7 Mal wieder unser Chill-Step-Stream.
Das ist immer so entspannend. Gucken, dass es nicht zu laut ist.
Ah, das ist gut. Da ist man doch gleich schon viel entspannter.
Und deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, wir splitten das auf. Wir machen da eine Server-Komponente und eine Klein-Komponente.
Die Klein-Komponente kann er sich in seinen Installer einbauen.
Da hat er wahrscheinlich einen Custom-Installer oder irgendwie so ein Windows.
Das heißt, bei Windows bootest du ja nicht über...
Also du machst keinen PXE-Boot, du machst etwas PXE-Boot.
Windows kenne ich mich eigentlich gar nicht großartig mit aus. Deswegen hab ich gedacht...
Was? Vor allem so automatisch in der KVM-Instanz?
Verstehe ich nicht. Zumindest hab ich mir gedacht, wir machen da eine Server-Komponente oder Kleinkomponente drauf.
Die Kleinkomponente kann er in seinen Installer einbauen.
Und die macht nichts anderes, wie Autodiscoveren im gleichen Netzwerk, wo quasi die Server-Komponente Autodiscoveren.
Und sich von dort einen gültigen Key abholen. Windows aktivieren.
Und wenn es geklappt hat mit dem Windows aktivieren, dann den Key, quasi dem Server sagen, Key löschen.
Und das Schöne daran ist, wenn wir quasi schon eine Server-Komponente bauen, die Autodiscovered werden kann,
können wir natürlich da auch noch ein bisschen ein Web-Service dranhängen,
wo er im Web-Interface beispielsweise gucken kann, welche Keys noch verfügbar sind.
Da kann er neue Keys hinzufügen. Weil mit der Text-Datei auf dem NAS bin ich mir gar nicht mal so sicher, ob das so eine sinnvolle Idee ist.
Das kann man immer noch einbauen. Ich denke, die bessere Variante ist wahrscheinlich so ein Import-Knopf,
wo man einmal die Keys importieren kann und dann über das Web-Interface managt.
Muss man mal gucken. Aber das mit dem NAS funktioniert natürlich auch, das ist kein Ding.
Aber wir werden das Ganze so aufsplitten ungefähr in ein paar Minuten.
Wir basteln quasi einmal eine Server-Komponente, das muss dann auf irgendwie einer Kiste im gleichen Netz laufen,
sonst finden das die Kleins nicht. Das sieht dann folgendermaßen aus.
Oh, da ist er. Jetzt wo du gerade da bist, muss das unbedingt eine Text-Datei auf dem NAS sein.
Also es ist nicht so, dass es nicht funktioniert. Aber über ein Web-Interface wäre das doch viel schöner.
Weil über ein Web-Interface könnte man zum Beispiel an so Dinge auch noch auswerten wie,
keine Ahnung, wann welche Keys verwendet wurden und sowas.
Könnte man automatisch mitloggen lassen.
Beziehungsweise du siehst auch, was du für einen Key-Verbrauch in der Woche hast
oder welcher Rechner welchen Key eingelöst hat und solche Dinge.
Ich brauche Paint gar nicht.
Also ich glaube, wenn ihr das nicht unbedingt auf dem NAS braucht, dann ist das glaube ich so viel schöner.
Ich mache einfach mal, du kannst dir das ja danach angucken, ob das letztendlich so passt.
Die einzige Sache, die du noch machen musst ist, also wenn ich du sage, meine ich Hardware-Rat,
ist, du musst das mit der Aktivierung dann mal ausprobieren.
Weil ich kann alles hier lokal bei mir testen, ob das funktioniert.
Auch das Discoveren im Netz und sowas, was ich halt bei mir lokal nicht gescheit testen kann,
ist, ob die eigentliche Aktivierung klappt.
So.
Okay.
Fangen wir mal an.
Also ich habe mir das, wie gesagt, ich habe mir das folgendermaßen gedacht.
Sie brauchen einmal eine Server-Seite.
Die machen wir wie gehabt.
Da haben wir jetzt ja schon ein bisschen Erfahrung mit gesammelt.
Machen wir mit ASP.NET Core.
Und wir brauchen eine kleine Seite, mit der fangen wir auf.
Und wir brauchen eine kleine Seite, mit der fangen wir auch an.
Wir machen eine kleine Seite, die den Server quasi...
...discovert...
Ich muss das nochmal aufmalen, wie das Ganze dann funktioniert.
Nur das, was man irgendwie checkt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das...
Versteht man das, wie ich das meine?
Also zum Beispiel, man hat einen Windows-Installer.
Da ist quasi der Activator-Client drin oder wie auch immer man das Ding nennt.
Und den starten sie dann nach der Installation.
Klicken sie drauf.
Oder lassen sie automatisch von der Installation starten.
Keine Ahnung.
Ist ja im Endeffekt auch egal, wer den startet.
Dann guckt er im Netz, wo er gerade ist.
Wo denn der Server steht.
Wir machen ein Broadcast ins Netz.
Wo der Server steht, der die Keys kennt.
Wenn er den gefunden hat, dann ruft er sich von dort einen Key ab.
Aktiviert Windows und sagt, dem Server kann er den Key löschen.
Versteht man, was ich vorhabe ungefähr?
Oder muss ich das aufmalen?
Das hat nämlich den Vorteil, man kann alle Settings auch lokal am Server machen.
Also zentral.
Und muss keine Konfliks verteilen oder so.
Heute mal wieder ne Runde Battlefield.
Ich hab' letzten paar Tage gar kein Battlefield mehr gespielt.
Mir hat's schon wieder fast gereicht.
Leute, ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen,
wie sehr ich mich darauf freue, also fiktiv,
weil man weiß ja nicht, ob es wirklich so ist,
darauf freue, wenn wirklich Bad Company 3 rauskommen sollte.
So, also.
Wir fangen mal mit zwei Sachen an.
Wir legen mal die Web-Anwendung an, ohne dass wir da was machen.
Wie nennen wir das Ganze?
Hardware Rat, hast du irgendeinen Wunsch, wie das Ding heißen soll?
Letztendlich ist es egal, man kann es immer so unbedenken.
Ich brauch' jeden coolen Namen für.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich mein, wir wollen es ja schließlich nicht Web-Application 2 nennen.
Das klingt irgendwie ein bisschen hängen geblieben.
Also, wenn wir das...
Ob der am gleichen Rute hängt oder so, ist egal.
Der muss im gleichen Netz hängen.
Der muss im gleichen Netz stehen, wie die Systeme, die aufgebaut werden.
Also IP-technisch muss der im gleichen Netz stehen.
Das ist wichtig.
Sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Wenn es da nichts gibt, dann baue ich das trotzdem,
weil das die schönere Lösung zu bauen ist.
Und dann verwendest du den kleinen Teil meinetwegen einfach nur zum Aktivieren
mit dem Sauber bleiben.
Aber wie gesagt, du warst ja am Anfang nicht da.
Warum ich überhaupt die Lösung mit dem Sauber vorgeschlagen habe,
Sauber-Klein-Geschichte, ist...
Erstens, weil es natürlich die saubere, schönere Lösung ist.
Und zweitens natürlich auch, dass wir hier was zum Basteln haben.
Weil das eigentliche Aktivierungs-Skript sind wahrscheinlich so...
Naja, irgendwie so 15 Zeilen PowerShell oder sowas.
Deswegen, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal und dann kannst du dir das ja mal angucken.
Aber der Sauber muss im gleichen Netz stehen.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Sonst funktioniert das nicht, weil wir machen UDP-Auto-Discovery.
Und das geht nur ins gleiche Netz.
Wir könnten vielleicht Multicast machen, falls der Router...
Falls der Router...
Nee.
Geht Multicast ohne Weiteres über den Router drüber?
Er muss ja eigentlich, oder?
Nee, oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab mit Multicast so wenig gemacht bisher.
Wie?
Genau, Keylogger.
Jetzt wurde ich enttarnt.
Ich will eigentlich nur auf die ganzen Hardware-PCs den Max-Keylogger draufbringen.
Okay, wie nennen wir das Ding jetzt?
Proggers.
Wir nennen es einfach Proggers.
Mir fällt gerade nichts anderes ein.
Wir machen das so.
Wir nennen die Server-Seite Proggers und die kleine Seite Proggers.
Dass man das überhaupt nicht mehr durchblickt, glaube ich.
So, empty-project, kein HTTPS.
Zack.
So, wir fangen mal mit dem client an.
Weil ich bin mir nur nicht ganz sicher, wie man das beispielsweise machen kann.
Dass man aus einer...
Quasi aus einer eigenen Anwendung, dass man dort einen zweiten Prozess startet
und Admin-Rechte anfordert.
Muss man ja für Windows-Aktivierung.
Also sprich, ich würde gern quasi dann dort drinnen dieses Aktivierungsprogramm starten
und das muss dann halt ein Popup kommen für...
Oh, das ist eine nice Idee.
Coggers für client.
Oh, das gefällt mir.
Moon Beer Desmond.
Das finde ich richtig gut.
So, ähm...
Erden wir mal ne...
Warte, was mache ich denn da?
Neue Solution wollen wir adden.
XSolution.
Wo ist er?
Da.
Ähm...
Wo steht's?
Console-App.
Okay, da heißt die Console-App, heißt Coggers.
Okay, also.
Von der Idee her, wir müssen jetzt erstmal so grob den Ablauf hier basteln
und danach, als erstes bauen wir auf jeden Fall die Autodeskavali.
Weil da habe ich nicht so wirklich Ahnung, wie man das macht.
Das Webinterface ist dann...
Webinterface halt.
Kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen.
Aber mit der Autodeskavali muss ich mal gucken.
Wir brauchen als erstes mal ein schönes Banner.
Äh, gibt's sowas wie Ficklit Online?
Ich weiß, dass es...
Bevor er jetzt sagt, Alter.
Ich weiß, der Name ist dumm.
Ficklit.
Aber Ficklit hat eigentlich gar nichts damit zu tun, wie es sich anhört.
Das ist ein Tool unter Linux, mit dem man Banner-Schriften machen kann.
Und wir gucken, ob es das online gibt.
Sonst muss ich in die VM.
Brauchen wir für eine Console-Anwendung...
Ja, sowas da.
Wir brauchen für eine Console-Anwendung erstmal ein tolles Banner, was angezeigt wird.
Das ist das A und O bei jeder Console-Anwendung.
Eine Console-Anwendung ohne schönes Banner ist unbrauchbar.
Das Auge ist mit, auch als Admin.
Was schreiben wir da rein?
Activator.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Das sieht alles ganz schön kacke aus.
Böh.
Oh.
Oh, das sieht doch ganz gut aus.
Oh ja, das ist gut.
Activator.
Ja, das finde ich viel besser.
Dann machen wir das A noch weg.
Naja, so ist das nice.
Banner.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal richtig einrücken.
Moment, wo geht es los?
Banner.
Da würde ich sagen, hä?
Ach nee, Moment, du bist falsch.
Das gehört ja dahin.
So, der Activator.
Gucken, wie das jetzt aussieht.
Das wichtigste.
Zwar das unsinnigste, aber automatisch gleichzeitig mit das wichtigste.
Äh, fuck, falsches Projekt.
Ich will nicht Progas starten, ich will Kogas starten.
Activator, ah wunderbar.
Geht schon gut los.
Jetzt kann es gar nichts mehr schief gehen eigentlich.
Okay, also von der Idee her brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Wir machen das alles in Main.
Der Client, der wird wahrscheinlich so 50 Zeilen lang, oder so.
Also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall einen UDP Client.
Mit dem wir dann unser Autodiscovery Zeug machen können.
Und dann brauchen wir auf jeden Fall noch einen Web Client, wir nennen das Ding auch.
UDP Client.
Dann brauchen wir auf jeden Fall noch einen Web Client.
Mit dem wir von unserem Server später Key anfordern, Key löschen und sowas können.
So, ich muss jetzt nochmal gucken, dass ich hier im Chat nichts übersehe.
Ja, Programm fertig.
Banner ist da.
Kein Problem.
Easy.
So, machen wir da nochmal eine neue Zeile drunter.
So, und dann haben wir irgendwie sowas, dass man auch ein bisschen sieht, was das Ding macht.
Search for Key Server.
Ich meine, das ist ja nur Fake Ausgabe, macht ja noch gar nichts.
So.
Und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie, da muss ich erstmal den Serverpart basteln zum Autodiscoveren,
dass das funktioniert.
Also von der Idee her sagen wir dann irgendwann, also so, hier müssen wir jetzt Autodiscovery
Server, den es ja noch gar nicht gibt.
Hier müssten wir also Server found oder irgendwie sowas.
Dann müssen wir Key, dann müssen wir den Key abrufen, dann lassen wir so ungefähr den
Flow haben von dem, was dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, Downloading Key oder sowas.
Key from.
Und dann kommt dann hinten die IP vom Server oder irgendwie die URL vom Server an, woraus
es sich herholt.
Na ja, und dann wird aktiviert irgendwie sowas.
Also wir basteln jetzt erstmal den Autodiscovery-Geschichte.
Warum kann man den nicht zoomen?
Weil ich kein Partner bin.
Speicher das doch als Textdatei und lest das Ganze dann als Ressource aus.
Kannst die Datei ja als Ressource, was, das Banner?
Ne, das Banner ist jetzt nichts, was man als Ressource speichern muss.
Soviel ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Welche Cherry MX Switches benutzt die Dossatur?
Speed?
MX Red Speed oder irgendwie so?
Ich hab ne, ah das Ding hab ich.
Da sind, lass mal gucken, was da Switches, ja.
Cherry MX Speed.
Ist das.
Ich hab mich jetzt mittlerweile ganz gut dran gewöhnt, auch wenn ich die Tasten immer noch
einen Ticken zu klein finde.
Ich hab das Gefühl, die sind so 1-2 Millimeter unterschiedlich zu anderen Tastalturen.
Kommt mir irgendwie so vor.
Naja, zumindest, äh, sag mal, Pixels bei euch in der Vorschau auch so oder liegt das?
Ne, ich hab meinen Vorschau auf 360p stehen.
Da muss man sich jetzt nicht wundern.
Lull.
Eieiei.
So, ähm.
Ok, weiter geht's.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal den Autodescover-Teil basteln.
Ähm, wie gesagt, unsere Server-Seite ist wieder ASP.NET Core.
Das heißt, wir können, hab ich nämlich jetzt in einem Tutorial zugelesen, wir können hier
nämlich einen Service hosten lassen.
Also man braucht gar keinen Windows-Server oder so, äh, keinen Windows-Server oder sowas
zu machen, sondern man kann den Background-Service mittlerweile direkt in ASP.NET Core hosten
lassen.
Aber vorher machen wir unseren eigenen Ordner.
Ordner.
Services.
So.
Add.
Inks.
Äh.
Discover.
Service.
Stellen wir das mal hier oben.
Was ist das für Autotune-Musik?
So, und dann brauchen wir hier sowas wie I-Hosted-Service.
Implement-Interface.
Visual Studio.
Deswegen muss ich sagen, Visual Studio ist für mich die beste Idee.
Das ist das, das, das, das fließt so, wenn man das verwendet irgendwie.
So, ähm.
So, jetzt müssen wir irgendwie das Ganze hier starten, dass der, der, der, der, der,
der, also von der Idee her wird das jetzt so laufen.
Jetzt brauchst du auch nochmal Paint.
Von der, von der Idee her wird das so laufen.
Also jetzt brauchen wir mal eine Kiste.
Was ist das?
Server-Kiste.
Äh.
Wir machen das anders.
Warum mache ich das überhaupt mit Paint?
Wir können doch irgendwie Draw-IO oder so verwenden.
Ist doch viel schöner.
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen, ich will es nicht speichern.
Decide later.
Server.
Ja.
Sehr schön.
Server.
PC.
Ha.
Krass.
Was da alles drin ist.
Klein.
Sieht eins hässlicher aus als das andere.
So, klein.
Es ruckelt.
Viel zu fett das Ding.
Also von der Idee her, wie kann man hier Pfeile jetzt machen?
Pfeile.
Ja.
Nice.
Also.
Äh.
Also von der Idee her funktioniert, äh das ist scheiße zu bedienen.
Aber das dicker machen.
Aha.
Oh.
Geh weg.
Also von der Idee her wird es jetzt folgendermaßen funktionieren.
Ähm.
Kann man da was drauf schreiben?
UDP.
Broadcast.
Also.
Der Klein macht ein UDP Broadcast zu Port 888 oder Port, keine Ahnung.
Denken wir uns.
Gibt es einen Port, der gut zu Hardware Rat passt?
Äh.
Keine Ahnung.
Port 841.
Ne, das ist zu viel.
1, 2, 3, 7, 6.
Keiner ist es vollkommen egal, welcher Port.
So, der Kleine der wird jetzt, ich muss mal selbst aufmalen, dass ich umgefallen bin.
Idee vollkommen, was wir jetzt machen.
Also der Kleine wird jetzt.
UDP Broadcast machen auf Port.
1, 3, 3, 7.
Ja, aber das könnte schon belegt sein.
Fortwende.
Ja also, der Kleine macht jetzt ein UDP Broadcast auf Port 1, 2, 3, 7, 6.
Das ist so shab, das wird sonst keiner verwenden.
Dann schickt ihm der Server eine Antwort.
Also der Server lauscht auf, also da, der beindet sich an Port 1, 2, 3, 7, 6.
Und dann schickt er ihm eine Antwort zurück.
An ihn.
An ihn direkt.
Schickt er eine Antwort zurück und da steht dann drinnen.
So was wie, da schicken wir ihm den Jason zurück, wo dann drinnen steht IP und Port vom Server
slash irgendwie AP Keys oder sowas.
So und schon ist das ganze auto-discovered.
Die Frage ist, was soll das werden?
Warte mal, ich zeige es dir nochmal.
Also der gute Hardware-Rat, der möchte ein Skript haben, was ihm sein Windows-Zeug aktiviert,
aus einer Text-Satei vom NAS.
Ja, wir waren schon öfters auf deine Webshop im Stream.
Wir haben, die Leute sagen auch immer so nach dem Motto, was hatten wir letztens?
Irgendwie hat einer letztens sowas geschrieben wie, was sagst du zur XY, sonst war es Grafikkarte
bei Hardware-Rat.
Da haben wir gleich nachgeguckt.
Guck da.
Was haben wir uns jetzt schon alles angeschaut?
Nicht wirklich viel außer die Homepage.
Naja, zumindest Tira Fox, also nachdem das hier ja ein bisschen zu wenig sophisticated
ist, ein PowerShell-Skript, was so Dinger macht, bauen wir da jetzt eine zweiteilige
Geschichte.
Einmal einen Webservice, wo er die Keys drinnen verwalten kann, dass man das nicht mehr über
Text-Satei gefuddelt auf dem NAS machen muss.
Und dementsprechend können wir auch eine schöne Auswertung machen im Webinterface,
so nach dem Motto, wie viele Keys werden heute verbraucht, vielleicht kann man sich daraus
auch ableiten, wann muss man neue Keys bestellen.
Und vor allem, wann wurden die Dinger eingelöst?
Das ist glaube ich ganz interessant.
Da kann man immer nachgucken.
Im Zweifelsfall kann man sogar, ich weiß nicht, setzt du irgendwie den Username auf
Kundenname oder so?
Weil da könnte man sogar uns noch merken bei den Keys, wie der Username hieß, von dessen
Account aus der Rechner aktiviert wurde.
Dann hast du sogar eine direkte Zuordnung, wer welche Windows-Keys gekriegt hat.
Wir brauchen jetzt erstmal einen UDP-Service.
Ja, genau, Thürer Fox, das Schöne daran wird, man muss halt irgendwie die Sache dann
verbinden, sprich der Client, der die Konsolenanwendung, die auf den Rechnern dann mit dem Key
Windows aktiviert und auf dem Server.
Und nachdem man ja die Config nicht quasi überall hinmit verteilen will, versuche ich,
dass das Ding sich autodiscoveren kann im gleichen Netzwerk.
Also er macht dann irgendwie einen UDP-Podcast, der selber antwortet.
Ansonsten, was auch immer geht, ist natürlich, kannst du die IP direkt eintragen, das funktioniert
natürlich auch.
So, das heißt wir brauchen jetzt hier auch auf jeden Fall einen UDP-Client.
Man muss sich nicht wundern, nicht wundern, einen UDP-Service gibt es nicht.
Da müsst ihr Microsoft fragen, warum es das nicht gibt.
Microsoft hat sich gedacht, ein UDP-Client reicht auch, mit einem UDP-Client können
wir auch selber machen.
Ich bin verschrieben, ich bin irgendwie verschrieben gerade.
Ich bin verschrieben, ja, ich bin irgendwie verschrieben.
Die Frage ist, wie sicher das Ganze ist, gar nicht.
Muss es aber auch nicht, weil es nur lokal bei ihm im Netzwerk ist.
Das hat keinerlei User, ich meine, wir könnten da noch irgendwie eine Basic OS oder sowas
davor machen.
Aber ich habe jetzt keine User-Authentifizierung oder sonst was geplant.
Was ist der Vorteil von UDP, in dem Fall jetzt gar nichts wirklich.
Der Vorteil ist ein bisschen, dass du Discovery-Podcast mit TCP nicht machen kannst.
Logischerweise geht das mit TCP nicht.
So, also wir starten jetzt den UDP-Client und dann müssen wir irgendwie sagen, ich muss
mal was nachgucken, Leute.
Ich muss mal kurz beim anderen Rechner was kratten.
Ich habe da nämlich den UDP-Client schon ein paar Mal drin, den UDP-Client, dass ich
mal ein Beispiel finde, wie man den Kramplett jetzt richtig verwendet.
Warum geht das nicht?
Weil du bei TCP immer eine Sequenzen hast.
Du hast ja bei TCP immer eine Session.
Ja doch, eine Session hast du bei TCP immer.
Du musst ja bei TCP sagen, ich möchte eine Verbindung aufbauen.
Und das geht natürlich immer nur mit einem Ziel, ganz billig gesagt.
Und wenn du jetzt einen Podcast rausschickst, wenn du das Ziel nicht kennst, wenn du einfach
sagst an alle, dann geht das mit TCP nicht.
Irgendwie geht es bestimmt auch.
Du könntest das so machen, wie Plowhead Up sagt.
Du kannst quasi Nmap machen, du kannst jede IP scanen, aber das ist aber nicht der Zweck
der Sache.
Du machst einfach den UDP-Podcast und lässt die andere Seite anfahren.
Das ist die viel schönere Variante.
In dem Tempo, wie wir heute weitermachen, wird das aber nichts.
So, wo habe ich denn hier was?
UDP-Client.
Ein bisschen Spicken aus dem Kopf, weil das ist auch nicht alles auswendig.
Also, als erstes müssen wir einen Task starten, das ist schon mal klar.
Return, Task, Run, Zack, Bam, Task, Run und da drin sagen wir jetzt, wir packen den ganzen
Kram erstmal in den Task rein, Task, Run, UDP-Client, dann sagen wir ihm, wie geht das?
Aha.
So, wir pasten mir das jetzt einfach mal von dem anderen Zeug, das ich hier noch habe.
Bei uns heißt es UDP-Client, UDP-Client, Endpoint, Port 8, 8, 8, 8, wollen wir nicht, wir haben
gesagt, wir nehmen Port, was?
Port 1, 2, 3, 7, 6.
Das ist so ein Schäpperport, den werde ich mir nie im Leben merken können.
Kannst du einen Command-Project machen?
Ja, ich habe für die anderen Projekte schon alle Commands, allerdings...
Für das hier haben wir einen Mod am Start, sonst immer ein Mod am Start, sind die ganzen
Mods?
Nicht, dass es jetzt noch Aufstände gibt oder so, weil die Mods nicht da sind.
Na mal gucken, vielleicht kommt ja gleich noch einer.
All die konnten das machen.
Keine Mods da.
So, weiter gehts.
Der Sebaro, da ist er doch.
Jetzt hat einer gefragt, ob wir nicht für das hier noch einen Command machen können.
Der Sebaro kann das gut.
Der Sebaro, können wir das wieder so machen, ich laber jetzt noch mal kurz 30 Sekunden,
was wir hier heute machen und dann kannst du einen Clip von machen als Command irgendwie
einfügen.
Also, wir basteln ein Tool für Hardware-Rad, dass er seine Windows-System aktivieren kann,
allerdings nicht einfach einen PowerShell-Script, wie er sich das vorgestellt hat, sondern
ein bisschen anspruchsvoller.
Wir machen einen Server-Teil und einen kleinen Teil.
Den kleinen Teil kann er sich aber auf den Kundensystem verteilen zum Aktivieren, natürlich
dann wieder löschen, da lässt man natürlich nicht drauf.
Und das Server-Teil, da kommen die ganzen Windows-Lizenzen rein und der Client holt
sich das dann vom Server ab und löscht es dann auch da wieder.
Und im Web-Interface vom Server kann man dann so Auswertungen machen wie, was weiß ich wer
hat welchen Key aktiviert oder wie viele Keys in der Woche habe ich...
verwendet oder sowas in der Richtung.
Irgendwas.
Einfach, einfach weil es zu langweilig wäre, einen PowerShell-Script zu machen.
So.
So, okay.
Ich kopiere...
Nein, wir machen das vorher.
Wir sind jetzt ganz brutal.
Endlosschleife.
Ihr wisst, ich bin Fan von Endlosschleifen, habt ihr das letzte Mal gesehen.
Ich tippe das jetzt mal ab von dem anderen, was ich hier schon mal gemacht habe.
Endpoint.
Und dann versuche ich mir noch mal irgendwie zusammenzureimen, was ich da hier gemacht habe,
wie das funktioniert hat.
Ne, das heißt nicht sauber, das heißt UDP Client heißt natürlich.
Und dann versuche ich euch zu erklären, was das macht.
Ich kann jetzt schreiben.
Encoding.
Ach, ist nicht importiert, deswegen geht das nicht.
ASCII reicht uns, wir brauchen keine speziellen TIFF-8-Dinger.
Okay.
Also.
Von der Idee her macht das jetzt folgendes.
Wir registrieren das jetzt als neuen Hintergrund-Service bei ASP.NET Core.
Muss das ein Server sein mit Windows oder Linux oder reicht das nass?
Was ist denn das für nass?
Ist das irgendwie ein Synology oder sowas?
Weil wenn das nass ist, wo man Docker drauf laufen lassen kann.
Jaja, das geht.
Das reicht.
Da muss ich bloß noch eine.NET Core Anwendung draus machen.
Hab ich noch nie gemacht für Docker auf dem nass laufen lassen.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber das hat natürlich seinen Vorteil, wir lernen auch wieder was bei.
Das kann kein Docker?
Warum kann das kein Docker?
Oh, nee, oder?
Ja, das kriegen wir schon irgendwie zum Laufen.
Irgendwie geht das.
Wenn nicht, mache ich dir halt ein PowerShell-Script.
Das können wir immer noch machen, ja.
Aber so ist das viel geiler.
Haben wir auch was zu tun.
Also.
Von der Idee her.
Was ist das hier?
Wir registrieren das jetzt als Hintergrund.
Ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen hinne machen, sonst wird das nichts.
Wir registrieren uns jetzt als Hintergrund-Service für unser ASP.NET Core Programm.
Startup.
Services.
HostedService.
Unseren Discoverservice.
Und mehr müssen wir nicht machen.
Ich zeige euch das mal.
Wenn wir das Ganze jetzt starten.
Ich mache jetzt hier mal sowas.
Was weiß ich.
Hallo.
Wenn wir das Ganze jetzt starten.
Ach, Moment.
Wir sollten das richtige Projekt zum Starten auswählen.
IES.
Woodface.
Ja.
Oh.
Alles gut.
Moment.
Oh.
Ich sollte vielleicht mal den Port ändern.
Das läuft jetzt auf dem gleichen Port wie das Memetool.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Moment.
Das muss das Memetool mal kurz auf den anderen Port machen.
Das ist ja nicht wirklich.
Jetzt mal Refreshen auf der anderen Seite.
Geht noch.
Alles gut.
Gut.
Und den hier können wir laufen lassen.
Ja, guck hier.
Hallo.
Ja.
Das trifft es eher.
So.
Also da startet uns jetzt unseren Hintergrund Service hier in einem eigenen Thread wieder.
Oder ich wurde jetzt letztes Mal belehrt.
Das ist kein eigener Thread.
Das ist ein eigener Task.
Was nicht immer genau das Gleiche ist.
Wollen wir hier keinen Blödsinn erzählen.
Und da läuft jetzt einfach eine Endlosschleife.
Die darauf wartet, dass irgendwelche Clients UDP Broadcast Messages schicken.
Wird das Projekt auf GitHub veröffentlich?
Kann ich machen.
Kann ich fabrics stack zur damaligen.
schon in der anderen sprache gemacht hat und jetzt in den laden kommt der quasi
hauptsächlich sie schab und dort net macht das kriegt man auch relativ gut
hin ich meine es ist natürlich ganz cool wenn man die standard library kennt und
ich meine die dort net standard library ist schon ziemlich groß und wir
mittlerweile ist fast alles drin
ah für für asp.net backend schwierig zu sagen also ich habe asp.net
backends selbst noch nie professionell gemacht command ist erstellt perfekt
nice
ist schon wieder abgekackt warum
ist das miemtool abgeschissen was soll das
hier sebaro nice gemacht
kackt es vielleicht ab wenn ich das hier starte
was ist das für ein scheiß wenn mich das verarschen
dann starte ich halt ohne die bagger
was warum geht das zu hä warum geht das zu wenn ich das andere schließe was
macht visual studio dafür komische dinge im hintergrund ok ich mache es
einfach mal aus und starte es hier drüber was falsche
äh ok wo ist das problem visual studio was machst du denn für komische dinge
was ist das denn hier wieder
ja ich starte schon extra ohne die bagger
ja ist gut
so und warum warum genau beendet sich das jetzt wenn ich das hier starte und
beende macht es nicht mehr ok ich habe keine ahnung was das eben war aber jetzt
funktioniert perfekt so also wir werden es jetzt folgendermaßen machen wenn der
wenn das ding ein udp broadcast und ein podcast empfängt mit der response
message discover muss uns irgendwas ausdenken was wir reinschreiben dann
antworten wir damit kopiere ich mir aus dem projekt raus dann antworten wir dem
typ der angefangen also von der idee her ist es jetzt folgendermaßen hier im
hintergrund läuft jetzt halt der udp server und wartet darauf dass er eine
broadcast message vom klient kriegt wenn er eine broadcast message message vom
klient kriegt in der drinnen steht discover dann schickt er an den klient
zurück eine message wo er das web interface findet was natürlich also
nicht das web interface wohl den webservice findet was natürlich sehr
nice geschichte ist dann kann quasi der klient autodiscoveren wo er weitere
informationen findet das ist sehr sehr nice
habe ich habe irgendwas noch im augenwinkel gesehen dass irgendwer
gefragt hat warum ich kein kein konzol redline mache oder sowas ich sehe es
jetzt nicht wirklich
ach florian echt das habe ich auch gemacht mit meinem ds light habe ich
übelst auf twitter umgeflammt bis sie das gemacht haben
was ist das für ein webserver framework das ist von sie schafft nie das ist
asp.net core das ist dabei
also ich finde die nachricht nicht mehr in er hat gefragt warum ich nicht noch
irgendwie eine konsole redline machen muss ich mein wozu muss ich nicht ich
start ich habe hier eine endlosschleife drin die schleift sich einfach ein ab
und irgendwann wird sie mit dem rest beendet
so also wir brauchen jetzt eine message die wir zurückschicken an den klient
da machen wir eine schöne jason message eine schöne jason message jason
konwörter
ne konvert konvert war es serialize object und das ganz cool gemacht da kann
man einen anonymen typ reinstecken und sagen wie man das ganze aufbauen will
und wir sagen einfach also das ist die message die dann beim klient letztendlich
ankommt und wir sagen dem einfach nur wo man und ich weiß dass das so nicht
funktioniert ich sag so bevor jetzt irgendeiner sagt max da steht aber
localhost drinne das ist die message die man den
klient schicken wo hand anhand dessen er dann weiß wo das server steht und unter
welchem port dann das web interface und die api verfügbar ist was war das für
ein port 5000 es ist standard asp. net core port 5.000 api kies damals in sonn
hier wir könnten dem klein auch initial noch ein bisschen mehr information
übermitteln aber das passt schon so und daraus war jetzt ein byte array weil das
ding unbedingt sprites haben möchte was irgendwie kacke ist weil das einfacher
wäre mal direkt ist dringend übergeben kann aber kann man nicht
falls ich falls ich irgendwas über sehleute müsst ihr noch etwa bloß
dabei schreiben so wie es im chat steht weil ich kann mich nicht hier auf
programmieren konzentrieren plus die ganze zeit auf den chat das heißt wenn
ich im augenwinkel rot sehe dann sehe ich das besser
also jetzt sagen wir hier encoding get bites die musik eigentlich laut genug
also jetzt die musik gerade aus aber wenn sie denn läuft doch nur hier beides
beides beides beides beides end point session gut das müsste jetzt erst mal
reichen auf server seite jetzt können wir gucken ob das discover auf klein
seite funktioniert
das ist die musik abgekackt gerade
ok starten wir mal
starten wir mal die asp.net core geschichte so und jetzt gehen wir mal in den
client rein und gucken ob wir den server discovered kriegen wieder ein bisschen
spicken musik passt ok so wieder abgucken search for keyserver das heißt
da sagen wir jetzt weil das machen wir machen wir hier oben
endpoint ip endpoint das ist immer ein bisschen redundantes getippe bei dem
euren zeug podcast so der klein muss den udp podcast schicken den der server
dann quasi erhält und ihm die antwort schickt wo er das web interface findet
und zwar auf port wie ist der kram jetzt noch ich kann mit diesen port nicht
merken die wir uns ausgedacht haben port 123 7 6 das port ist so schepp den kann
man sich echt nicht merken so
gut search for keyserver response dp klein kleinschreiben ist sie nicht wie sie
send vorher muss ich noch sagen aha ist gut dass ich hier schon mal was hab
wo ich noch ein bisschen abgucken kann von früher broadcast enabled muss man
nämlich noch setzen weil sonst geht's net
so
jetzt kann ich sagen send und jetzt muss ich wieder eine message schreiben mit den
ganzen krempel wieder machen er message gleich discover
weil das ist immer der gleiche kram and coding haben wir noch ausgehen
kohlen direkt nehmen kohlen get bites das kann man bestimmt irgendwie kürzer
könnten wir in extension method bauen oder ich glaube das ist eine ganz gute
idee wir könnten extension method bauen die quasi string to byte array ascii
macht anstatt dass man jedes mal diesen ganzen schwuppel da machen muss
das wäre ganz nice message
send und da muss jetzt der endpoint rein den wir da oben erstellt haben das
richtig so und wenn das jetzt funktioniert sollten wir eigentlich als
response ok ich will erst mal gucken ob es prinzipiell funktioniert test test
ja ok server faun ok prinzipiell funktioniert das ganze das heißt wir
haben jetzt an den server was geschickt jetzt müssen wir gucken ob wir eine
ordentliche antwort kriegen das heißt dazu sagen wir jetzt
udp kleint kleinschreiben die kleinten receive vom end point
macht das richtig glaube schon
das ist falsch was hier gemacht hat siste ich muss ihm jetzt sagen dass es
an den port schicken soll
broadcast
das ist für die antwort dann so end point
so end point und da müssten wir jetzt eigentlich als response vom server was
bekommen bin ich mal gespannt ob wir da irgendwas kriegen
zweimal response können wir das ganze nicht nennen
response message so jetzt gucken ob das funktioniert so ja nice wir kriegen
geschwuppelt zurück das ist auch schon mal schön so das heißt da gucken wir
jetzt response message gucken wir mal rein ob da auch jetzt das richtige drinne
steht und danach erzähle ich das noch mal was das jetzt eigentlich macht für
alle die es nicht so ganz mitgekriegt haben
response message so da müsst ihr jetzt drinstehen hier als antwort die adresse
vom server wo ich das das eigentliche interface finde ja guckt da soll ich
mal erklären was das jetzt macht oder konnte mir so insoweit folgen
also wir haben wir haben uns in der server komponente da starten wir einen
udp server auf port 1 2 3 7 6 und der lauscht auf udp broadcast pakete
wenn dann in judi hier sieht man das wenn dann in udp broadcast paket empfängt
was unser klein schickt und wenn dort drinne die message discover steht dann
schickt er ihm zurück wo der kleint das den eigentlichen service findet wozu
brauchen wir das ganze im prinzip ganz logisch der kleint weiß nicht wo es den
service zu finden gibt also sprich wenn euer klein nicht weiß also wir schreiben
jetzt mal eine ip rein ist es glaube ich eindeutiger wenn der kleint nicht weiß
jetzt müssen wir neu starten sonst dann steht es nicht drinne also wenn der
kleint nicht weiß wo er denn den eigentlichen service findet kann er
nichts machen das heißt man müsste jeden kleint von hand konfigurieren und sagen
hier guck mal den service wo du dir eine weitere informationen findest der ist
da wenn man das nicht will und ein server im gleichen netz stehen hat kann man das
auto discoveren lassen also sprich man schickt vom kleint aus
einen udp broadcast paket los mit der message discover das jetzt was ich mir
ausgedacht habe das kann man machen wie man will und dann antwortet das server
darauf mit der informationen wo genau jetzt also konkret mit der ip den port
und der kompletten uhr wo es weitere informationen gibt das heißt so kann
man quasi auto discover wo man hin muss mit dem kleint ohne dass man das selbst
ohne dass man es quasi an jedem rechte eingestellt kriegen muss das ist ganz
praktisch und so wie es aussieht klappt das auch hier guckt doch ganz da ist
ok mit was machen wir jetzt weiter mit der server seite mit der kleinen seite
weiter sagen wir machen wir mit der server seite weiter wir machen mal so
ein minimales web interface dass man so ungefähr sieht was da am ende rein
soll also dazu legen wir uns mal auf server seite ein paar neue ordner an wir
brauchen nämlich einmal controllers wir brauchen
wie data oder so und models brauchen wir also mvc ganz klassisch so in unseren
models ordner legen wir jetzt mal eine klasse an für den windows key den
dinger nennen wir jetzt auch windows windows key oder gibt wie heißen die
dinger wie er wie heißen die dinger eigentlich offiziell die heißen ja nicht
windows key und die heißen nicht windows serie noch mal wie weiß jemand
zufällig wie das richtig heißt wohl volumen lizenz nie wie wie heißt das
windows wie nennt man das eigentlich
cheat 1905 ich will es in letztendlich nichts das ein weiter death streams geben
allerdings muss ich auch mal wieder ein paar sachen spielen ich bin schon gar
nicht mehr großartig dazu gekommen irgendwas zu spiel lizenzschlüsse
windows lizenz ist aber ziemlich blöd dass auf leisens key
hier nennen wir es windows leistungs windows leistungs ok so und so eine
windows leistungs von der idee hat nachdem das ganze in den model in der
datenbank wird in der sql datenbank braucht das ding auf jeden fall eine id
da kommen wir nicht drumherum dann braucht es dringend dann braucht das
ding den eigentlichen cd key hier kommt der eigentliche cd key dann rein also
hier was 123456-1234- das ding
cheat 1905 warum fragst du willst du mehr entwicklung streams oder würdest du dir
wünschen dass es mal wieder ein bisschen mehr gaming streams gibt so dann sind wir
erstmal richtig pro und dann machen wir noch sowas rein da stehen die ganzen ruby
leute drauf dann speichern wir uns noch wann der lizenzschlüssel quasi
eingegeben wurde also brief war man angelegt haben und dann speichern wir
uns noch wann das ding just add fällt mir nichts besseres ein
gaming was spielst du so in letzter zeit habe ich hauptsächlich battlefield
gespielt nach vor ewig overwatch und da waren wir richtig gut haben wir richtig
guten overwatch aber da haben wir es verkackt und blitz hat auch deswegen
spiel war nicht mehr so
und dann speichern wir uns noch also mir fallen jetzt keine keine tollen tollen
namen für die dinge ein also von der idee her ist das so hier kommt dann in
der datenbank also datenbank hört sich jetzt zu übertrieben an das wird so
billig sqlite ding also nicht viel besser als ein textfile
da wobei kann man so nicht sagen sqlite ist ist an sich gar nicht schlecht
kleif tritt zu ich glaube viele leute gucken einfach zu weil sie den technik
kam interessant finden und können mir oftmals gar nicht so richtig folgen
deswegen frage ich immer zwischendurch nach ob man alles soweit checkt was ich
treibe und oftmals stelle ich dann fest ich habe mir selbst nicht richtig
gedanken zu gemacht und es geht gar nicht
jetzt ihrer fox da müssen wir uns da mal gedanken drüber machen wenn es so weit
ist warum lässt du manchmal eine zeile frei beim
code schreiben das ist mein bauchgefühl wie sachen zusammengehören also zum
beispiel used ad used folge hat irgendwie zusammen created ad ist alleine und key
und id ist auch relativ unik und ähnlich das hat keinen tieferen sinn so also von
der idee wenn wir das so machen hier kommt er so hier kommt der windows key
rein der cd key also hier irgendwie weiß ich wie die die sind so die cd keys
eigentlich aus wir brauchen nachher noch ein ziel leute wir machen jetzt
kooperative ja man konnte das auch im jason speichern aber wobei mit mit ich
glaube es ist einfacher wir müssen uns jetzt mal kooperative machen und zwar wir
brauchen später noch einen richtig coolen regex für windows cd keys wir
müssen ja gucken nicht könnte ja sein dass er dass sie sich vertippen oder
vercopy pasten und dann wäre miss drin das wollen wir ja nicht windows 10 key
example wie sind die keys eigentlich mittlerweile aus
jetzt ins instant wird spannen raus hier guck mal 1 2 3 4 5 minus 1 2 3 4 5 also
es sind 5 mal 5 ne sehe ich das richtig ja 5 mal 5 da kann ich hier rein und hier
kommt rein wann das ganze keyfile ne ne brauchst du aber das ist das einzige was
hat er selbst jetzt muss wirklich ob das aktivierung funktioniert
in view i think it's better to go to youtube and watch tutorials from someone
who who has more experience in view
musik eskaliert ernsthaft
ok so hier schreiben wir mal der key angelegt wird hier gucken wir hier also
von der idee her machen wir das so der client sagt dann wenn er windows
aktivieren konnte hallo selber ich habe windows aktiviert bitte diesen key
entfernen und dann zu diesem zeitpunkt schreiben wir hier rein wurde dann wurde
der key gejusst das heißt man kann man hat so ein lock wer was aktiviert hat
so ein just vor können wir dafür verwenden dass dort dann auch drin
steht der benutzer account von dem das ausgeführt wurde weil vielleicht ich
weiß ja nicht genau wie er es macht aber vielleicht heißen ja die benutzer
account von je nachdem wie der kunde heißt und dann würde dann quasi auch
hier noch hier drinne stehen für wen welcher cd key verwendet wurde das
eigentlich ganz ganz nutzlich wenn wir die information eh schon haben dann
können wir sie auch verwenden habe gerade der problem mit dem handy auf dem
wie gesagt ich erwarte nicht dass du das jetzt komplett anguckst da kannst
gucken wenn es dir gefällt ansonsten kriegst auch so du musst nicht gucken
was soll das program später machen mach mal aus rufe zeichen
ähm was für ein befehl haben wir aus rufe zeichen hr tool jetzt werden sie
alle also ok eine sache machen wir jetzt noch wir sagen hier so was wie ist
used und immer neues die schraub sieben feature wenn jetzt nämlich die zeit was
mache ich denn hier ich kann aber auch nicht mehr richtig tippen wenn nämlich
die zeit noch die ford ist also sprich wenn used ad noch nicht gesetzt ist
irgendwie so das ist nicht der schönste check aber mir fällt gerade kein
bessere ein wenn die zeit noch nicht gesetzt ist dann wurde der kino nicht
verwendet das ist ein bisschen einfacher als immer mit einem datetime zu
hantieren ok das ist unser model für die datenbank
jetzt brauchen wir ein package und zwar wir brauchen wir brauchen
nein
es hier leitende auf fack wie ist das
nee wir brauchen ente die framework oder auch fack wie ist der ach du scheiß
wiesen der kram wieder die suche in wöchel zu der so kacke wir brauchen
ente die framework wie heißt das ding ente die framework sq light brauner
144 ja übelst krass äh oder
ok mwc können wir schon mal hinzufügen das brauchen wir auf jeden fall auch
wie heißt denn das
mal gucken wie das in nunget heißt ich finde es auch also ok ich finde es auch
toll dass man die sachen besser über über die webseite findet als im
visual studio selbst halt microsoft logik
hardware hat ich hätte noch mal die frage wie könnte man nämlich auch einbauen
nachdem wir jetzt ja quasi schon der server komponenten haben und den client
der windows aktivieren kann wenn wir das fertig haben wäre es relativ einfach
was einzubauen dass der client noch zusätzliche befehle ausführt also wenn
du irgendwie quasi nach dem windows aktivieren noch ein paar dinger machen
möchtest wie zum beispiel ein
die die programme von dir löschen
also wenn du jetzt eben die server komponenten haben und den client der
windows aktivieren kann wenn wir das fertig haben wäre es relativ einfach
was einzubauen dass der client noch zusätzliche befehle ausführt also wenn
du irgendwie quasi nach dem windows aktivieren noch ein paar dinger machen
möchtest wie zum beispiel die die programme von dir löschen
die die programme von dir löschen also mal angenommen der letzte schritt den du
immer macht des windows aktivieren und danach löschst du alles von hardware rat
runter könnte man das dann beispielsweise auch noch hinterlegen dass
der irgendwie einen custom script am ende ausführt so nach dem motto ich
bin mit allem fertig custom script ausführen kann sich dann auch
runterladen kannst du quasi auch zentral verwalten und dann lädt sich das
kript runter und flutsch macht alles weg was da drin steht da musst du nicht
mal selbst aufräumen automatisches formatieren von den unformatieren
platten also das kann ich nicht einbauen aber ich kann die möglichkeit einbauen
dass das ding sich den script abruft dass du hinterlegen kannst was er machen
soll und es ausführt zum schluss noch da musst du halt gucken wie man das wie
man das macht mit den platten formatieren so irgendwie in power shell
oder in in batch oder sowas so jetzt haben wir sqlite kommt noch hinzu zack
sehr schön ja wir akzepten alle terms wir akzept immer alle terms gibt es
irgendjemand der das liest jetzt wirklich jemand der die lizenzbedingungen immer
liest
power shell batch ja was denn jetzt es gibt ja nichts anderes unter windows
power shell oder batch eins von beiden was anderes hast du keine chance
ok data jetzt brauchen wir noch ein db kontext ab db kontext und den kopieren
wir uns weil easy db kontext easy life wir kopieren uns das einfach aus dem
board drüber viel besser ab db kontext db kontext import es sind license ne wie
habe ich den krampl jetzt noch mal genannt windows license heißt auch nicht
wie ist keine ahnung licenses options options bla sonst was das brauchen wir nicht das
ganze müssen wir noch registrieren was ist use ich kopiere es mir einfach auch
hierher warum warum soll man alles aus dem kopf wissen und warum soll man
alles immer neu basteln ist es auch einfach aus was anderem kopieren kann
ja ja plus dass wenn es hier keine mim db hinzufügen sondern eine keine
ahnung license db import import zack dann machen wir noch use mvc use mvc
mvc ok was auch immer
ad mvc mein wing das ist bei microsoft immer nicht so ganz doch ist sogar
relativ konsistenz hier unten ist es use und da oben ist es ad
use mvc das da unten kommt weg use mvc use file server und wir initialisieren
die datenbank auch gleich
db kontext also das ist das schöne das dependency injection schon komplett mit
dabei ist bei asp.net kurz das halt sehr praktisch das heißt ich muss jetzt nicht
hier irgendwie sagen new app kontext sonst was so einfach hier injecten
rein und sagt dann irgendwie x database ensure created das heißt wenn die
datenbank noch leer ist liegt das auch an mit dem schema wie es sein soll was
mache ich eigentlich use files aber
use files aber dazu dass das funktioniert müssen wir noch was hinzufügen
und zwar ich glaube static files static files ja dass ich mir den krams
mittlerweile schon merken kann ist echt der wahnsinn wieder wenn man das oft
genug macht dann merkt man sich wirklich den größten ist ok blabla files aber
jetzt gucken wir mal was passiert wenn wir starten ob irgendwas abkackt oder so
ne guckt aber die datenbank wird erstellt sehr schön und er zeigt nix an weil ich
noch keine seite ab die raten zeigen soll was irgendwie logisch ist das heißt
belegen jetzt meine html seite an item html index html so wenn ich das jetzt
starte sollte eine lehrer html seite kommen ja sehr schön lehrer html seite
so und da schreiben wir jetzt irgendwie um so was hin wie hardware rat keys
irgendwas dass man sieht das was drauf steht
wir brauchen einen font wir brauchen ordentlichen font kopieren wir uns
ordentlichen font hier view brauchen wir noch haben alles noch
wir machen inline css wir brauchen extra css drauf hier mein regex
oh man da hier ein regex den kopier ich mir mal rüber mal gucken was das da
sieht schon mal abenteuerlich aus auf jeden fall der regex geht back
behind überhaupt ist das look behind oder ist das look behind
fragezeichen doppelpunkt geht das überhaupt noch nicht
hast du schon mal versucht mit noten applikation zu meinen ja aber noch nie
was ernsthaftes also der regex sieht schon mal sehr abenteuerlich aus also ich
vermute mal was er macht ist das ist zeichengruppe word characters also
word characters in dem fall klein a bis z groß a bis z 0 bis also prinzip fast
alles aus der lehrzeichen und sonderzeichen moment funktioniert das
fünf fünf word characters genau fünf word characters gefolgt von dem minus und
das ganze vier mal ja weil das letzte hat kein minus hintendran gefolgt von
fünf word character der regex die ganz das sieht eigentlich so aus als müsste
funktionieren ja
die heckschrift art heckschrift art verwende ich verwende ich nur unter linux
und im terminal dass ich habe das gerne dass ich quasi ein bisschen andere
schriftarten zwischen den systemen habt dass ich gleich direkt weiß was was ist
was administrator hat ne das muss ich mal gucken wie wir das machen mit den
benutzer namen mal schauen ok aber weiter jetzt haben wir eine lehrer
html seite wo hat verrat kies drauf steht ist hier baro jetzt tun wir nicht
so ok wie fangen wir jetzt am besten an um das auszuprobieren
ich würde sagen wir machen auf unserer html seite einfach einen formular wo wir
mal ohne kontrolle irgendwie sinnlos cd keys rein pasten können und einfach
gucken ob er das in der datenbank speichert das heißt wir brauchen jetzt
den controller den legen wir von hand an und dann in
ich nenne ihn key controller weil license ist es mir zu lang
key controller controller base
ja und ich copy paste ich mir das hier von dem anderen zeug mal rüber
api controller
api controller kies haben wir gesagt als url
das das waren wir jetzt wir lassen alles auf alles auflisten bringt uns
nichts weil wir haben ja nix windows so da müssen wir uns noch eine
datenbank kontext in checken dass wir auf die datenbank zugreifen können
db kontext bm das mag ich schon visual studio ist echt
nice so turn licenses gut so und jetzt machen wir den post zum anlegen von
neuen zum anlegen von neuen keys post post key from form hier machen einfach
mal ganz machen als einfach auf der seite ein formular mit text area wo wir
keys pushen können
also wie man schon pollution
Okay
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal ob das posten von der website ausgeht
So vom form Ich versuche jetzt mal von der webseite wir machen jetzt eine text area drauf also wir sagen jetzt hier mal form das wird ganz billig form action nach api
Slash keys method post und da versuchen wir jetzt ach so ja form encoding brauchen wir noch ein enk type
multipart da sagen wir jetzt text area da kann ich mal richtig einrücken text area a b c name wie haben wir es hier genannt das muss gleichheißen
sonst kann er das nicht mapen keys dann brauchen wir jetzt noch einen button um das ganze zu submitten type submit so wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe sollte ich eine webseite haben mit einer text area und ein formular wo ich okay es sieht mega hässlich aus das muss ich noch mal zumachen
das sieht wirklich richtig aber safe ich weiß wie wir das machen edit text area columns ne wie war das rows rows 50 ja komm mal rows 30 columns 50 dann siehts ein bisschen schöner aus
okay das sieht zwar sehr behilflich aus jetzt gucken wir mal ob das posten zum solber funktioniert also hier könnte man dann keys reinpasten a b c network mal gucken ob es geht
das hat funktioniert alter guck da das sind die sachen auf der serverseite die wir gepostet haben first try
easy first try okay dann dann sagen wir jetzt mal mal gucken ob das von der logik her funktioniert für jeden key wir splitten das keys split oh jetzt kommt wieder wind aus schiss
das funktioniert bestimmt nicht wisst ihr uns so fast jeden betriebssystem tut das aber vom wind aus tut das wieder nicht richtig wenn ich sage split online ending es gibt wieder probleme ohne ende
ich weiß das jetzt schon ich weiß jetzt schon dass es nicht funktionieren wird richtig ich dachte wir machen das nämlich so weil normalerweise hast du ja quasi ein eintrag im web interface für ein
ding in der datenbank ja aber nachdem er wahrscheinlich eine liste hat mit 500 cd keys ist das über so ein textfeld zum rein copypasten doch etwas schöner zu managen als add key
ein key add add key nächster key add das ist blöd da brauchst du irgendwas zum reinpasten hier so deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir machen das so machen einfach den textfeld wir machen das noch ein bisschen ein bisschen schöner
oder ich weiß nicht wie viele keys hast du so in diesem textfall drinne stehen so dass wir ungefähr wissen was da auf uns zukommt an an menge was ist was was ist die bauch immer noch als die ach du scheiße
100 stück ja das kann man easy easy handeln über welche wege kriegst du die keys kriegst du die per mail oder kriegst du die aus ein microsoft account oder vielleicht könnte man das abrufen auch irgendwie automatisch machen
ok aber ich weiß jetzt schon das splitten wird nicht richtig funktionieren ich habe es im gefühl irgendwie weil windows line ending rum spacken wird ok aber wir machen das jetzt erstmal ganz billig wir fügen einfach mal alles ein
also sagen wir hier key also wir müssen erstmal neue license anlegen per mail aha ok wir müssen neue license anlegen license key wird der key hier im input license
created ad wird datetime now license aber sonst überhaupt noch was used ad used for ne gibt's noch nicht so und dann sagen wir license ad license und hier unten speichern wir den ganzen kram in die datenbank ad ohne recx ohne check ohne sonst was
dafür mal gucken ob es geht a b c gucken ob das safe netz funktioniert ja ne hat er gemacht sqlite browser gucken wir mal nach ob der kam jetzt in der datenbank drin steht müsste jetzt eigentlich funktioniert haben
bin los gefuddelt da wieder so pro stater zack da stehen die keys drin in der datenbank used ad created ad ist auch auf dem richtigen datum gesetzt wenn ein key nicht funktioniert server spackt oder so muss da nicht funktionieren der nicht funktionierende der bleibt einfach in der liste stehen es werden bloß funktionierende keys gelöscht
sofern man diesem windows aktivierungstool entlocken kann ob es funktioniert hat oder nicht aber das muss das ding das ding wird ja irgendwie melden hat geklappt oder hat nicht geklappt also ich würde die keys nur löschen wenn das aktivieren geklappt hat und sonst bleiben die einfach drin
so
jetzt mit dem splitten funktioniert nicht warte mal ich weiß dass das ich kann euch jetzt schon sicher sagen dass es probleme machen wird ähm split new line cross platform was gibt es denn da schönes easiest way to split cross platform
das da ja gut auf die idee wäre ich auch gekommen
icing dog alle haben eine gute idee wo dann planoifully und klickauf sao mitnummer brick
nee das ist das muss vier pearl gehandhabt werden mal machen das letzte letzte sache isolation erzalt sie funktioniert
mal machen so als letzte letzte sache wenn sonst nicht funktioniert
einfach vom kleinen array mit pre-split keys in den body
ja da müssen wir dann müssen wir aber das submitten irgendwie intercepten also
sprich wir können nicht einfach submit machen von der form sondern müssen quasi ein eigenes
submit machen aber es wäre sicherlich nicht verkehrt wenn der client den kram schon splittet
also ich fände es ganz cool wenn man schon direkt hier sowas
reinkriegen würden vom vom kleint das wäre nicht schlecht kontrollieren ob das reggex
match oder sonst was was ist wenn der client kein java script enable hat dann geht das ganze
frontend nicht das können wir machen das finde ich nicht schlecht das merke ich immer split
und kleint aber reggex geschichte und so müssen wir trotzdem hier machen das heißt wir lassen
es jetzt erst mal so und gucken uns dann danach an wird das auf github veröffentlicht ja ich denke
schon da ist ja nichts hardware rat spezifisches im eigentlichen sind drinne
simplified es doppelt so lang easy simplified mache aus mache aus drei zeilen fünf simplified
spritz spritz endings spritz options remove empty nun aber die move empty ist auch nicht
schlecht dass der ganze schmatter weg der noch übrig bleibt
das ist kein auftrag im eigentlichen sind ich habe gesagt das passt ganz gut ich kann sowas
machen und was eignet sich super für ein streben wäre es nicht einfacher dass man auf
dem server die seit die keys aus der text datei holt doch prinzipiell schon du hast wenn du es
rein in der text datei machst natürlich mehrere probleme erstens was passiert wenn mal zwei
leute gleichzeitig ein system aufbauen und du kannst hier keine zusätzliche information
speichern wie zum beispiel wann es aktiviert wurde für wen es aktiviert wurde wann der key
eingespielt wurde und dementsprechend auch keine auswertung mitmachen das wäre halt die 20 zeilen
powershell variante so jetzt jetzt brauchen wir unseren krassen regex wo haben wir hier
regex weil es werden bloß ninger eingefügt die ordentlich geregex sind dass da nicht
irgendeinen miss drinne steht das einlesen der das einlesen der keys ja kann man doch
also ach so du meinst so ein import button oder so ja das könnte man machen
als nächstes kommt noch einer mit an wäre eine powerpoint datei nicht besser
oder das allerschlimmste wäre eine lotus notes konflikt nicht besser so ok jetzt
bauen wir uns unseren unseren geilen regex pattern und mal gucken ob der funktionierende regex ich habe
irgendwie miss copy pasted oder der regex sah doch nicht so aus oder doch der sah so aus
das sieht hier viel breiter aus oder latex könnte man es auch machen richtig
so moment jetzt erst mal mal kurz kurz jetzt muss das ding erst mal ordentlich regex regex
match key pattern nur wenn das funktioniert fügen wir es ein sonst fügen wir es nicht ein das
heißt unser ganzen komischen schwubbel keys hier die können wir jetzt nicht mehr einfügen wenn
sie nicht schon drin sind das geht jetzt alles nicht mehr ich sollte das redirect ausschalten
ne ok das einfügen funktioniert nicht mehr das heißt unser regex funktioniert mal mal gucken
ob unser regex jetzt die ordentlichen dinger durchlässt wir wollen nicht redirecten wir
wollen redirecten doch wir wollen wieder regex wieder auf die startseite so schmeißen wir die
datenbank mal wieder weg weil da ist ja Mist drinne und jetzt gucken wir mal ob der regex
wirklich funktioniert jetzt bin ich mal gespannt also 12345 12345 zack das sollte gehen ach so
ich habe ja noch nichts ich habe noch nichts was die keys wieder abruf den lull aber wir können
mit dem wir können mit dem sqlite explorer mal gucken ob es richtig geschrieben hat ja
hat er used ad ist nicht gesetzt created ad erster key drinne ok funktioniert das heißt
er fügt auch wirklich nur keys ein die richtig sind du musst überprüfen ob was übrig geblieben
ist ja moment natürlich der regex ist so nicht richtig so ist schöner also sprich
wort anfangen dann der regex und dann ende das heißt alles was darauf nicht match darf
nicht rein das war zwar ein guter hinweis
doch das machen wir irgendwann das wäre es jetzt ein web klein der automatische e-mail zu abholen
woher kommt in deinem post die ok methode form vom base controller und ok in redirect geben
halt einen i action result raus was dann asp.net core irgendwie matching macht so ja das funktioniert
auch schon mal eigentlich ganz gut so also das ist auf jeden fall noch verbesserungswürdig
wir können auch keine keys gescheiten löschen und sonst was aber an sich ist es doch schon
mal ganz nice jetzt brauchen wir noch was moment warum heißt das noch get memes falsch
get keys ok und dann brauchen wir noch was für unseren client der einen key abholte
mal get key und zwar als mal gucken wie das aussehen muss das war mir jetzt so wir wollen
einfach irgendeinen freien key abrufen das heißt dann müssen wir sowas hier aufrufen
im endeffekt guckt also wir müssen sowas hier machen wie api keys free und dann kriege
ich irgendeinen woops dann kriege ich irgendeinen freien key und jetzt kommen wir wieder zurück
zu dem warum ich das vorhin eingebaut haben dass man abfragen könnte ob das ganze schon
benutzt wird oder nicht hallo jan das andere kann ich nicht aussprechen aber jan kann
ich zumindest schau mal erken licences where jetzt kommt trick 17 where license is not
used das geil oder jetzt kriege ich quasi die erste wobei wenn ich schon sage die erste
first und default oder was anderes machen jetzt kriege ich quasi die erste den ersten
windows key aber will ich sagt der nicht in der nicht benutzt das lechern leistens man
das könnte ja auch sein dass es nicht funktioniert na das könnte ja auch sein ich weiß gar nicht
kann man hier irgendwie sowas machen wie return was macht man eigentlich wenn ich ich kann
ja nicht return return 404 ja ich weiß nicht wie man 404 return ich habe keine ahnung
das gute frage hat der p code status status kohler und wir wollen kein innere wir wollen
nur eine licenz haben ja gut das geht es natürlich nicht weil man kann ja status code nicht zu
windows das muss man kugeln kugeln mc type status kohlt action resulti moment das ist
action resulti und zwar wenn los leistens jetzt funktioniert das doch als i actually
salt action resulti ok so funktioniert das gibt es not found answer not found not found
ist ja nicht so doch warum eigentlich ja doch finde ich ganz nett so ist das schick so jetzt
können wir wieder zurück wechseln zu unserem client und mal schauen ob das abrufen funktioniert
was heißt das ei das ist eine weil es das ist ein interface autotune autotune beste
gut jetzt gehen wir mal unseren kommandos ein kleines zurück so wir haben jetzt hier
discovered das bitte so ein bisschen den schmorder den wir nicht gemacht haben löschen
mal wieder also wir haben jetzt discovered die url wo wir hinmüssen in response message
steht das drinnen wobei response message response message ist chasing das müssen wir
passen jason ah da ist es doch gefuckt da war es doch eben das weep nice du willst du
haben so die volle wieb lade für alle
ich bin verwirrt was wollte ich jetzt machen
genau ich wollte ich wollte passen jason konvert war das jason konvert die serialize ich hab
das noch nie ausprobieren ob das funktioniert dynamic was status code auf 418 was ist 418
ich bin ja das machen wir das ist nice dass es das überhaupt gibt ne schon wieder total
gestört warum um alles in der welt gibt es den offiziellen htp status code ich bin eine
t-kanne da sieht man halt dass zur damaligen zeit wo diese wo diese sachen gebastelt wurden
da halt schon auch die richtigen leute dabei gesessen haben die serialize objekt dynamic
geht das dann jason wie nennen wir das denn jetzt server settings heißt das so nein server
info ist da drinne oh nee dynamic geht nicht ah nee ich muss sagen was er deserialisieren
soll ok scheint doch zu funktionieren guck mal mal server info ah nee sekunde erst mal
erst mal progas starten und danach umschalten auf kogas so als ist kogas gestartet und kogas
funktioniert so das heißt jetzt können wir einen key abrufen mal gucken ob das funktioniert
ich meine ein key haben wir drinne oder hatten wir noch einen key drinne ich glaube einen
test key haben haben wir schon in der datenbank drinne und zwar ja xxxxxx test key sehr schön
das heißt jetzt nehmen wir unseren web client und sagen download string don't clone download
string adresse plus free wir können das noch viel schöner machen wir übergeben einfach
die ganzen dinger des cover service wir übergeben dem einfach hier base uhr weil da muss ich
den kram mit dem client nicht zusammen bauen ist doch viel schöner so base uhr key uhr
was von ich mir fällt das nix gescheites ein free und irgendwie so bescheuerte benahmung
irgendwie base uhr key uhr brauchen wir da gar nicht eigentlich key uhr ja gut die lead
muss ich mir eh selbst zusammen bauen ja die lead muss ich mir eh selbst zusammen bauen
aber da muss eine id hinten dran weiß jemand wo man aktuelle windows images runterladen
kann direkt bei microsoft hier starten wir das ding noch mal wechseln wir mal auf den
kogas und jetzt gucken wir mal ob es noch funktioniert ja ja ich weiß dass es download nicht funktioniert
z doppelpunkt free konnte er nicht finden aber jetzt ist ja auch nicht ist es base uhr
denn überhaupt base uhr nein wir wollen nicht base uhr wir wollen key uhr jetzt habe ich
es ja drei stunden später key uhr free gut ok mal gucken ob das geht hast du was vergessen
wie macht man in dynamic to string weißt du es wie macht man in dynamic in dynamic to string
keine ahnung wie das geht vielleicht sollte man es doch nicht als dynamic machen convert
to string was passiert wenn der aktivator beim aktivieren abkaggonics weil das löschen
des keys ganz am ende passiert wenn alles durch ist und überprüft wurde ob es aktiviert
ist aktuell ruft er sich nun in key ab und macht ja noch nichts convert to string so
es ist ja aktuell lauscht es ja nur an localhost ja dann stelle ich da noch mal localhost ein
bis wir es dann am ende die server ip stellen wo sind wir
was wenn zwei activator gleichzeitig in key request bekommen die nicht denselben wahrscheinlich
schon wahrscheinlich schon da müsste man irgendwie noch so was einführen wie irgendwie
pending oder sowas mal aufschreiben könnte man machen man setzt es ja doch das ist keine
schlechte idee man setzt es auf pending und danach auf used und pending keys werden nicht
rausgegeben moin maniac tv zuletzt vor zehn jahren ja das ist schon ich bin da schon eine weile ab start ja
das kann man vielleicht hier rein machen so mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert schreibt mal auf kogas
wieder um scheint hat scheint funktioniert zu haben leute scheint funktioniert so download
string da sollte jetzt der key drinne stehen war die license sollte da jetzt drin sein ja cool
seht ihr es license abgerufen key license dann lassen wir uns das wieder parsen als dynamic
in dem fall ist dynamic wirklich ganz nützlich normalerweise bin ich kein großer fan von
dynamic aber so jason geschwurbel ist das ganz ok license info ist jetzt genau das kriegen wir
zum server geschickt da steht der key drin das ist doch echt ganz nice so license info sondern
dann haben wir jetzt zur auswahl license in so all die key created blablabla ist used das juckt
uns eigentlich hier auf dem client alles nicht das heißt eigentlich könnten wir auch da gar
kein jason zurückschicken sondern einfach nur den stink normalen key aber dann können wir das
nicht mehr löschen richtig müssen wir mal gucken also ist so ist das auch auf jeden fall kein ding
so jetzt aktivieren wir windows irgendwie wie auch immer das funktioniert muss ich erst mal
nachgucken wie man das macht so und wenn wir windows aktiviert haben wir bauen jetzt irgendwie
was ein activate yes no console read key dann warten wir mal und danach jetzt tun wir mal so
als hätten wir windows aktiviert zu wir faken das jetzt einfach mal und jetzt löschen wir es jetzt
an wenn das ordentlich aktiviert und jetzt löschen wir den key von der selber seite aus
dazu brauchen wir ein delete ein delete brauchen wir dazu gucken wir uns wieder ab aus unserem
board viel viel besser da wissen wir nämlich schon dass es funktioniert was da drin steht delete delete delete delete key from root oder
wie der cisco fern sagen würde from route ist kontext feind id oder auch nicht für schmerzen
feind id kontext remove key und datenbank speichern
was was was ist cheat ich habe es nicht gelesen
ja der dps einschalten können wir immer noch das ist wirklich das kleinste problem an der ganzen
geschichte hatte dass da setzt du ein häkchen hatte tps an so kannst du windows aktivieren ja
ich weiß weiß dass das habe ich schon gesehen aber ich kann mein windows ja hier nicht aktivieren
das heißt das muss hardware auf jeden fall selbst ausprobieren dass ich kann hier alles testen lokal
außer dass eigentliche windows aktivieren und das verschlüsseln von den keys können wir auch machen aber
man sagen muss aktuell liegen sie in der text datei und verschlüsselt auf dem nass also das ist jetzt
weder besser noch schlechter hier return ok aber das können wir machen das ist eigentlich keine
schlechte idee schreibe ich mir noch rein enk keys in db können wir machen da müssen wir halt
in den schlüssel vergeben den wir dann auch irgendwo reinschreiben aber naja das ist lokal im netz scheiß drauf ok so windows aktivieren
fragezeichen ja so jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir windows auf magic art und weise irgendwie aktiviert
und jetzt löschen wir das ja master dom tv das hatten wir gerade schon den fall deswegen machen
wir noch ein pendingfeld deswegen machen wir noch ein pendingfeld hast du gelesen was hat
verraten kann dieses ding auch der server abspielen wo eine saunanlage dran hängt
wenn er deine windows du willst doch auf dem nass laufen lassen wenn er in einem nass
box dran hängt geht das auch wie das genau bei dir installiert können wir noch mal gucken
also was installiert wurde es wurde es jetzt genau drauf machst können wir noch mal gucken aber
wenn dort boxen dran sind kann man auch saunen abspielen aus doch heraus allerdings nicht von
windows system kein ding also wenn du auf windows system machst dann geht das auf jeden fall so
habe ich jetzt habe ich jetzt das delete eingefügt hier ich bin gerade ein bisschen verwirrt hier
delete delete key genau der delete key wird nur aufgenommen also nur die lead key wird nur
aufgerufen vom klein wenn das aktivieren erfolgreich war wir tun jetzt mal so als wäre
das aktivieren erfolgreich master dom das wäre ich erst mal nicht verfolgen sowas wobei man das
machen könnte wenn der rechner noch mal neu installiert das könnte man tracken man könnte
sich die id irgendwie speichern weiß nicht ob das ein szenario ist was gebraucht wird
man könnte sich man könnte sich ja hier just vor man könnte sich irgendwie hat für all die
oder so speichern für neu aktivieren das könnte man machen ja das konnte das könnte man tatsächlich
tun weil wir löschen ja keine keys sondern wir setzen keys nur auf just dass man im nachhinein
nachgucken kann was sache ist ok delete key oder progress so web client jetzt löschen wir
web client das jetzt ein bisschen eklig gemacht man muss jetzt sagen upload upload string ist
eigentlich egal was wir nehmen address ist server info base wohl was haben wir hier
ok das müssen wir mal kurz selbst zusammenbauen
wisst ihr was ich schreibe mal kurz hardcoded rein weil ich gucken will ob es funktioniert
plus license id license info id geht das so oder kackt es ab ok methode ist delete string data
leer brauchen wir nicht wollen es einfach nur löschen jetzt wie motoren 404 not found weil
weil warum ist not found was ist was genau was genau ist falsch
was genau ist falsch
das stimmt doch
delete 404 ok ich muss upload upload kann die kann man hier null kann man hier null
reinstecken irgendwie wie alter dotnet wie schicke ich denn einfach einen leeren delete
request an diese uhr ich will einfach nur delete request ohne payload schicken web client delete
das string empty haben wir doch schon gemacht gerade also das ist ja das gleiche im endeffekt
ok upload upload values new new was auch immer für eine collection
yes was warum warum
request delete api key 1 not found warum
warum ist es jetzt warum not found delete id
from not so eigentlich funktionieren ich irgendwo verschrieben ich mich irgendwo verschrieben
ja warum warum macht er das jetzt nicht
ist er noch ein key in der datenbank ja müsste und er würde mir auf jeden fall kein 404 werfen
wisst ihr was ich schreibe das jetzt mal hier von hand rein
delete so jetzt hängt es irgendwie alles jetzt gelöscht das ging jetzt
moment bin ich überhaupt verwirrt warum ging das jetzt und vorhin hat es doch exakt
die gleiche uhr oder auch nicht vielleicht auch nicht mit der kie sind wir noch drin
die bagen mit right line lull search for key ich glaube uns ist irgendwie das asp.net
den gerade ein bisschen abgeschissen activate jetzt hat es funktioniert vielleicht habe
ich vielleicht jetzt mal vorne erstatten sollen jetzt hat es funktioniert wenn ich
jetzt refresche kann man nicht refreschen jetzt ist der key weg ok nochmal neuer key einfügen
5 so edit key ist eingefügt key ist eingefügt irritiert mich jetzt dass
er so rumspack key ist eingefügt ok probieren das ganze noch mal aus activate yes jetzt geht's
ok keine ahnung was das gewesen ist jetzt funktioniert kein schimmer kein schimmer
was muss ich wieder in selbst so kacke schreibe es könnte sich irgendeiner copypaste um ihren
chat copypaste wenn ich wieder keys brauche ist das ein neuer twilight wenn ich hab drauf
funktioniert keine ahnung was das gewesen ist ok das ist doch nice also vielleicht sollten
wir jetzt noch zum abschluss also prinzipiell funktioniert jetzt fehlt hier noch das eigentliche
aktivieren aber so die grundlagen sind geschaffen also natürlich noch gucken wir mal wenn er
das wirklich aktiviert und das ein bisschen sicherer und schöner machen aber prinzipiell
klappt das aber die web die seite sieht halt schon mal mega hässlich aus also dann würde
ich sagen machen wir die wir machen jetzt noch die letzten zehn minuten die seite noch
ein bisschen schön dass es auch was hermacht also als erstes als erstes fügen wir viewjs
von innen cdn ein das werden wir auf jeden fall früher oder später brauchen so button
klas eikens edit ok jetzt haben wir schon mal ein icon drauf
dann waren wir da nicht h1 drauf sondern machen jetzt ein paar so funktionell und clean sieht
mega hässlich aus außerdem brauchen wir noch ein paar tabs für für history wer welche
keys eingelöst hatten so viel komplizierter wird die seite aber trotzdem nicht break dazwischen
ok dann machen wir jetzt mal ein steil steil steiler steil alles in line das wird so kurz
die seite da brauchen wir keine extra extra geschichten hier das wird vielleicht 60 zeilen
lang body kopieren wir uns das vom anderen wie wir das mit der schrift gemacht haben
die app ist es da das da alle musik wo geschwätzt wird ist so nervig mehr brauchen wir eigentlich
gar nicht aus die eine zeile so jetzt haben wir schon mal eine ordentliche schriftart schon
mal gut font so und da machen wir das nicht mit mit
und sagen wir font size wie 30 oder so 30 40 was nimmt man da wir brauchen auch wir
brauchen auch das hardware logo 40 die schrift größer ganz gut hardware logo gibt es auch
bestimmt auch transparent hier irgendwo transparent transparent wir fügen das direkt von youtube
ein load image image source das wird jetzt ein bisschen fett sein das bild
beim css gilt auspacken wenn ihr komisches tss sagt sagt mal bescheid ist dass ich nicht
der große css helfen was das image weil wir wahrscheinlich auch nur ein image haben image
wird content fit ne wie das content fit content muss ich abgucken content fit objekt fit
war das eine güte css objekt objekt fit contain clear fix den clear gut dass du sagst
ich hätte es jetzt wieder voll vergesse deswegen hängt der ganze mister auch rechts rum breite
50 pixel ah sieht schon besser aus clear ja ja cool wenn es keine keys mehr gibt gibt
es 404 sollte es nicht 418 geben wenn es keine keys geben sollte das müssen wir gleich nochmal
investigate wie macht man das klasse clear
kann ich nicht einfach sagen dass beides left ist doch so ist es besser beides left beides
left und dann machen wir irgendwie noch einen margin oder so was ist padding ist außen margin
ist in ich kann mir das nie merken ja das sieht doch jetzt ganz gut aus so darunter
kommt jetzt der navigation bar mit ein paar links drinnen links zu keys links zu logs
links zu stats sieht zwar scheiße aus aber das können wir noch anders da formatieren
klein so ah nee umgedreht padding in margin außen so rum an theon es gibt sogar relativ
viele die sich hier auskennen aber es gibt auch genauso viele einfach nur so zugucken
ja jetzt haben wir die seite noch ein bisschen hübscher gemacht man sieht immer noch wirklich
hübsch aus aber besser als nix so morgen werden wir dann machen dass das ding das front
an sich auch die keys alle abruft und sowas aber als basis ist das doch eigentlich schon
ganz nice also morgen machen wir das fertig nicht so wie das meme tool was ich seit wochen
schon hin zieht da kommt halt immer wieder was dabei morgen machen wir das fertig da
fehlt ja nimmer viel was wird gerade programmiert machen wir ausrufe zeichen hr tool sebaro
werden vorher sogar schon über 150 ja passt doch wie könnte man jetzt die navigations
leis noch ein bisschen hübscher machen ich kann so zs style style gedürfnis wenn ich
nicht gut daran da habe ich ja schon bei meme tool übelst einen abgebrochen wenn die buttons
und die textfelder sind auch kacke aus ich will mich noch verbessern was los sebaro das
meme tool ist kaputt wie im tool geht wieder kz fps gucke auch zu bringen sich habe ich
ja das neueste noch gar nicht erzählt wenn sie das für heute eh fertig mit progress oder
wir waren zumindest nicht mehr viel heute das war morgen fertig ich habe euch ja das
schlimmste noch gar nicht erzählt zwar also ihr kennt ja noch meine alte katze die hier
vielleicht kennt der dude was ich noch was zu sagen vielleicht kennt ihr auch ja meine
neue katze da habe ich auch schon ein paar mal gezeigt ja ja das war meine eine bein
die ich bisher hatte kann das ding nicht verschieben also nacheinander zuerst hatte ich die hatte
ich die und die die alte die war ja auch krank dass es war vor einem jahr danach habe ich
mir ich habe mir die hier habe ich mir geholt sie hat übrigens ich habe es mir nicht ausgedacht
sie heißt barbie das hat die vorbesitzer ihr den namen gegeben ich würde meine katze
nie barbie nennen und die habe ich mir erst irgendwie im april oder so geholt und die
wäre jetzt den letzten monat schon so krank dass sie gestern gestorben ist zwar ich habe
jetzt keine katze mehr gestern abend vom tierarzt haben sie einschläfern lassen die konnten
gar nicht mehr richtig laufen die ist also ich bin gestern heimgekommen ich bin gestern
heimgekommen und als die katze rumgelaufen übelst rum geeilt dass ich wusste ja dass
dass das irgendwann eintritt demnächst ja ich wusste halt nicht dass das jetzt schon
ist die weit die war ja schon quasi acht wochen hatte ja mehr oder weniger nichts gefressen
nur noch irgendwie also ja nierenprobleme gehabt zahnprobleme und nierenproblemen wobei
die nierenprobleme das eigentliche waren und da hat sie jetzt seit acht wochen kaum noch
was gefressen ich habe ihr immer so zusatzzeug gekauft obwohl sie halt noch ein bisschen
mit über die runden gekommen ist aber gestern bin ich heimgekommen da hat sie sich schon
immer so versteckt in den ecken und wenn sie rumgelaufen ist dass sie mit dem kopf
ist gegen die heizung gerannt einmal aus versehen weil sie kaum noch koordination hatte wir
müssen jetzt übrigens mal ich habe ich twitter schon wieder zugemacht twitter wieder zugemacht
wir müssen die katze müssen wir auch noch ins meme board aufnehmen dass wir beide haben
mau fps die hat doch kein spitznamen gekriegt die hatte ich noch nicht lang genug
weiß jetzt haben wir sie beide jetzt haben wir sie alle drinne ja und wie gesagt die
ist gestern schon den ganzen tag übelst übelst rumgeeiert wurde mir berichtet und dann abends
haben wir das auch noch ein paar stunden angeguckt und es war halt klar dass das kommen wird
aber dass es halt gerade schon gestern ist war halt kacke na jetzt habe ich wieder keine
katz mehr
ja das nur für den fall der fälle weil immer die leute fragen was macht die katz
jetzt wisst ihr das bescheid das macht nichts mehr und ich mag keine hunde ich war ja sogar
als die erste katze gestorben ist also sprich ja die hier war ich ja sogar im tierheim und
hab mal nach dem hund geguckt aber ich wäre mit hunden einfach nicht warm ich werde ich
werde mit hunden einfach nicht warm ich bin da auch zwei oder drei mal gassi gegangen
mit so einem kleinen also jetzt nicht so ganz ganz klein weil die finde ich irgendwie eklig
sondern so ein mittel klein aber ich komme mit hunden nicht warm ich heißt ich werde
mir wahrscheinlich wieder eine katz holen wo ist die facecam easy gibt keine facecam
kaboom handy gibt es da wieder was zu gucken ja ich habe ich habe ich habe im kaboom telefoniert
wir gehen wahrscheinlich nächste woche oder übernächste woche wieder was füttern eventuell
die nächste katze als baby holen ich will ja ich hole mir absichtlich ja stimmt eine
million abos youtube face reveal habe ich ganz vergessen ich hole mir absichtlich alte
katzen ja erstens weil kaum eine alte katzen holt also wenn du mal ins tierheim guckst
du hast so viele so viele katzen sind halt schon über acht oder so die sind halt schon
relativ alt und einen vorteil hat es wenn man sich alte katzen holt also ich finde es
relativ großer vorteil wie derf ich kann jetzt kostenpflichtige abos bei youtube machen
fällt mir gerade so auf weil das kann eben bei das studio oft wenn man den vorteil davon
sich alte katzen zu holen ist dass man halt weiß was man kriegt also sprich wenn man
die kennen lernt und man sich versteht dann kann man halt davon ausgehen man versteht
sich ja auch in einem jahr noch oder so die die ändern sich halt nicht mehr ja und wenn
du da eine hast mit der du nicht klar kommst kannst du auch sicher sein mit der kommst
du auch später nicht wirklich viel besser klar mein klar natürlich ändert sich immer
wenn wenn wenn sie dich deine kennt oder so ja aber alte katzen die wissen halt schon
was abgeht und entweder passt das zu einem oder nicht wobei er hier barbie hat ja übelst
rumgeschleimt im tierheim noch und danach wollte eigentlich nur noch wenn sie danach
war gestreichelt werden aber tun wir mal gucken also ich werde jetzt erstmal abwarten
bis ich denke mal irgendwie so so märz oder so da werde ich wieder gucken weil also ich
denke es ist auf jeden fall besser nach weihnachten zu gucken weil die ganzen spasten die sich
dann irgendwelche fiecher holen und nach weihnachten wieder zurückbringen gibt es ja leider oder
was heißt zurückbringen meinen teilweise sogar auch irgendwo aussetzen aber die meisten
sind der wenigsten doch so anständig und bringen die bringen das dann bringen sie
dann ins tierheim da ist dann wahrscheinlich nach weihnachten ist da wahrscheinlich voll
im tierheim irgendwann so januar oder so wenn den leuten dann auffällt auch kleine süßer
hund macht arbeit oder aber der kleine süße hund von vor zwei jahren ist nicht mehr klein
und süß und dann wird natürlich immer ins tierheim gebracht oder babykatze ist nicht
mehr babykatze babykatze ist jetzt groß und man hat babykatze nicht ordentlich beigebracht
wie es funktioniert und babykatze scheißt wohin die leute sind teilweise ultra bescheuert
in dem tierheim wo ich die wo ich die letzte wo ich die wo ich barbie geholt habe da war
noch zwei andere katzen das war glaube ich geschwister oder so und die wurden ein paar
tage vorher abgeholt da waren wir schon mal da wir waren ja ein paar wochen da und dann
waren die weg da haben sie gesagt hey die wurden mitgenommen habe ich so wunderbar dass
das für die geklappt hat als und dann bin ich sind wir wieder gekommen um mal die katze
abzuholen und dann waren die beiden auf einmal wieder da das war irgendwie so ein abstand
von drei tagen oder so wo man gedacht hat wie kann das sein erst wurden die mitgenommen
und dann drei tage später sind die katzen wieder da und die leute die haben tatsächlich
die katzen mitgenommen haben sich dann drüber beschwert dass die katze unterm sofa sitzt
und einen aus versehenen blumentopf umgeschmissen hat und anstatt jetzt muss man sich mal vorstellen
wie bescheuert die leute sind also man holt sich eine katze das heißt man muss sich ja
vorher schon mal irgendwie oder zwei stück man muss sich ja irgendwie vorher schon mal
geistig damit beschäftigt haben was das heißt ja oder vielleicht auch schon mal ein bisschen
im internet gelesen haben das ist dass das vollkommen normal ist dass die katze sich
erstmal unterm sofa setzt ja und dass wenn die katze rumräd halt auch mal was herunerschmeißt
aber dann zu sagen wenn bringt die katze wieder zurück ins tierheim was sind das denn für
leute ich meine kann sie die katze mitnehmen drei tage bei dir quasi sich halbwegs einleben
lassen und dann wieder zurück ins tierheim bringen das ist jetzt doch mal voll bescheuert
er und der hat der hat nur der hat nur im käfig gesessen und rumgemaut der eine weil
der hat die welt nicht mehr verstanden weißt du so erst ist der im tierheim dann wird
er mitgenommen freut sich rennt ein bisschen rum und dann kommt wieder wieder hingebracht
er hat es überhaupt nicht gecheckt da da da mau es geht hier ab ich check es ja mehr
aber kannst du nicht mal zurückbringen bloß weil sie weil sie unterm sofa sitzt und was
runter geschmissen hat ich meine man kann sich da drüber aufregen ja man kann versuchen
der katze schon wie begreifbar begreiflich zu machen dass es keine so gute idee ist aber
sein zeug muss man halt so hinstellen dass es nicht runterfallen kann also wenn die katze
jetzt eine tapete kratzt ja und man mal irgendwie ein bisschen klatscht oder krach macht dass
die katze checkt dass das nicht gewollt ist das ist ja ok aber dass man wegen sowas
instan sagt so nach dem motto nee also also katze die die plumentopf runter schmeißt
ne das geht nicht da bringe ich die katze wieder ins tierheim zurück ich weiß gar nicht
ob die leute überhaupt irgendwie was im hirn haben und und sich mal auch nur fünf minuten
gedanken vorher gemacht haben wieso ist sich eine katze zu holen ich weiß es nicht die
leute sind teilweise stumm ich würde die katze auch behalten wenn sie die tapete abreißt
ich würde der katze irgendwie versucht zu verklickern das tapete abreißen scheiß ist
es muss sich übrigens beim tierheim unterschreiben ne katzenumtausch ohne scheiß das muss
man unterschreiben mittlerweile dass das da du musst ja wenn du wenn du eine wenn du
eine katze aus dem tierheim holst musst ja quasi den richtigen vertrag unterschreiben
wo sowas wie wie rückgabe und sowas drinne steht also ist nicht so dass du einfach hier
gehst und eine katze holst und rückgabe unterschreiben musst unterschreiben was du was du
machst wenn sie krank wird und so aber da hab ich schon komplett drauf geschissen jetzt
oder so ich musste zum beispiel unterschreiben dass wenn sie krank wird dass ich dann irgendwie
sie die zurück bringe oder so irgendwie zurück bringe zum ich bringe doch meine katze nicht
wenn sie krank ist zum behandeln zu dem kack ich weiß nicht ob er kacke ist lasst
wir das mal weg aber ich bringe doch meine katze wenn sie krank ist zurück ins tierheim
dass er da vom tierarzt behandelt wird der der 150 andere am tag behandelt warum da
gehe ich selbst wohin gehe ich hier bei uns hin der kennt uns der kennt die katze warum
soll ich das machen was heißt rückgabe ja du kannst die katze umtauschen ob kein ding
kannst du unter musst du unterschreiben du musst die katze auch eigentlich wenn sie
krank ist wieder hinbringen und was total bescheuern aber ich meine ich habe es letztendlich unterschrieben
und wer will das ganze kontrollieren ja also wenn du eine katze aus dem tierheim holst
und das unterschreibst dann hat das dann hat das ungefähr wenn du das liest so den charakter
wie wende dir keine ahnung wie so ikea sofa holst oder oder sowas in der richtung ja also
wenn du den ikea sofa mit raten bezahlt und das unterschreiben muss ungefähr so ähnlich
ist es auch wenn du dir wenn du den vertrag der im tierheim für die katze unterschreiben
ist es richtig bescheuert aber letztendlich ist es halt da auch so du hast es unterschrieben
und es kann eh keiner kontrollieren wobei es halt auch total bescheuert ich meine letztendlich
ist dass meine katze wenn ich die geholt habe dann gehe ich auch mit der zum tierarzt und
gehe nicht zum tierheim und dann ist es total bescheuert ich will ja das beste für die
katze und nicht irgendwie so 0815 tierheim tierarzt der 150 an der katze auch noch macht
eigentlich sollte man unterschreiben dass man sie nicht zurückgeben darf ja wenn schon
überhaupt dann sowas ja aber es ist umgedreht du unterschreibst dass du sie zurückgeben
darfst und du unterschreibst auch in welchen fällen du quasi das tierheim ich glaube
geht los würdest du für die progas progas steams die low latency options aktivieren
ja ja kann ich machen wisst ihr überhaupt wie das funktioniert low latency options also
nicht wie man das aktiviert sondern wisst ihr was die machen kann ich euch jetzt noch
kurz kurz erzählen wisst ihr wie das technisch funktioniert mit mit low latency options auf
twitch also nicht nur auf twitch überall low latency options wie ist der zustand eigentlich
für die katzen im tierheim das das kommt drauf an in welchem tierheim du bist das ganz
unterschiedlich also der twitch stream und beziehungsweise generell streaming funktioniert
folgendermaßen das ist eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich billig ja und ziemlich simpel und
deswegen funktioniert wahrscheinlich auch so gut also es funktioniert folgendermaßen
du hast irgendwo wir sagen mal du hast eine kamera wo ein video stream von kommt ja oder
hier eine aufnahme vom bildschirm so und daraus machst du einen h264 stream und uploadest
das irgendwo hin zu twitch in dem fall so und was twitch dann macht also damit da an
der stelle ändert übrigens low latency option auch nichts dass ich den stream von mir zu
twitch schicken muss da ändert sich überhaupt nichts dran das interessante ist wie streaming
funktioniert zu euch beziehungsweise für den für den zuschauer an sich oder auch
auf youtube oder so im prinzip funktioniert das alles anders das ist alles hls streaming
hls ist glaube ich das htp live streaming so und das funktioniert folgendermaßen das
ist htp streaming das ist super billig wenn du wenn du nur aufrufst kriegst du playlist
du kriegst eine playlist und in der playlist stehen stehen dateien drin so 1 2 3 4 so und
jede datei enthält einen schnipsel vom stream von 2 sekunden und du machst eigentlich hls
streaming ist eigentlich nichts anderes wie dass du in regelmäßigen abständen die playlist
neu abruft und wenn du unten angekommen bist mit der nächsten playlist oben anfängst
in der nächsten playlist steht dann halt hier oben irgendwie 101 oder 12 13 14 im prinzip
ist hls streaming nichts anderes wie 2 sekunden 1 bis 2 sekunden schnipsel vom video in der
playlist das ist alles so und ich glaube die standard die die die die standardzeit also
die standardlänge von so einem von so einem videoschnipsel ist standardmäßig glaube
ich 10 sekunden und der intervall in wer in der das abruft keine ahnung ich weiß es
aus dem kopf nicht zumindest das einzige was low latency streaming macht ist diesen intervall
schneller und die und die zeitenkürze also sprich dann geht nicht 1 schnipsel geht nicht
mehr 1 sekunde sondern nicht mehr 2 3 sekunden sondern 1 schnipsel geht noch nur 0,5 sekunden
dementsprechend musst du den kram ja auch wieder schneller abrufen nacheinander so und
das problem was man daran sieht ist das kann natürlich schneller mal buffern bei dem anderen
hast du quasi eine playlist ach ja und du kannst natürlich auch nur buffern die dinger
die du in der playlist abgerufen hast weil die anderen kennst ja noch nicht also sprich
kannst du die konsole im chrome öffnen während du ein stream öffnen ist das ist eine gute
idee sie war und das machen wir da werde ich nämlich sehen dass das so ist wir gucken
jetzt mal mein stream an auf auf twitch sound ist aus guckt und wenn wir hier in das netzwerk
reingucken scheiß mal weg ja ok die machen irgendwie noch anderes zeug man sieht es
nicht richtig aber ich würde das gerne mal rüber machen wie kann man das denn jetzt
auf die rechte seite machen den kram die machen irgendwelche web assembly geschichten aber
ich gehe mal davon aus dass das im kern ja guck seht ihr das das ist die playlist die
hier abgerufen wird m3 u8 da kommt eine playlist jetzt raus guck das ist die playlist das ist
die playlist und in der playlist stehen wieder die einzelnen videos drinnen ts files die
einzelnen videos von jeweils ein paar sekunden und danach wird die nächste playlist abgerufen
so funktioniert hls streaming das ist eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich easy warum twitch jetzt
also ihre krassen random namen drin hat weiß ich auch nicht und mit low latency streaming
wird einfach der schnipsel wahrscheinlich sind es hier zwei sekunden der schnipsel
kürzer und der intervall wo abgefragt wird kürzer das ist alles dementsprechend ist
die chance dass es buffert bei low latency streaming auch logischerweise höher weil
dann kann man keine 30 sekunden mehr im voraus buffern wo man dann erstmal ein bisschen ja
buffer hat falls es mal hängen sollte und man nachladen kann wenn es bei low latency
streaming halt mal kurz hängt dann hängt es halt dann buffert es halt kd north wie kann
man programmieren lernen was das beste ist nicht zu sagen ich möchte programmieren lernen
sondern das beste ist wenn du eine idee hast was du machen willst und dann suchst du dir
das raus womit du das am besten umsetzen kannst du lernst das das ist für die motivation
auch deutlich besser anstatt zu sagen ich lern jetzt programmieren und habe eigentlich
keine erfolgserlebnisse dabei richtig sehbar auf empfängerseite kann man low latency aktivieren
ja dann dann ist gut ja ergibt ja auch irgendwo sin
ja was willst du dann machen was hast du eine idee kd north was du programmieren möchtest
weil wie gesagt einfach zu lernen ich ich lern jetzt programmieren ist schwierig immer
weil da fehlt einem so ein bisschen auch die motivation zu meistens kommt ja die sache
ich will jetzt programmieren lernen daher entweder weil man es für die schule machen
muss dann hat man keinen spaß dran oder aber oftmals kommt es ja daher dass man sagt ich
muss jetzt programmieren lernen weil der stein des anstoßes quasi irgendein problem ist
was man hat oder irgendwas was man gerne machen würde ja wenn man zum beispiel sagen würde
ich würde gerne webseite machen für xy keine ahnung für irgendwen und wenn das quasi
das ziel ist dann ist natürlich klar dann bringt es nix wenn man irgendwie bei speisen
ruby sonst was war wobei zum teil macht sondern dann sollte man sich schon mal hatte mein
java skript angucken ja also kardinals was was willst machen hast du hast du schon eine
idee kann ich dir sagen was du dir am besten für eine sprache angucken solltest ach so
die story mit dem typen in der bahn ja das wollte ich auch noch erzählen genau also
der dude hier auf
guck mal letztens in der bahn ich also die story dazu muss ja noch kurz jetzt davor davor
erzählen ich habe in der bahn gesessen habe gepennt auf einmal denke ich mir riecht irgendwie
komisch irgendwas riecht hier komisch und mache ich so die augen auf kukrum seh nix
und auf einmal auf einmal guck ich neben mich so hier guck ich neben mich und dann sitzt
der dude neben mir hier so und betet das ist einfach am beten gewesen neben mir ich weiß
nicht wie ich den scheiß groß machen kann weil twitter sackt der tipp ist jetzt neben
mir und betet guckt euch mal die ekligen füße an alter also ich habe keine ahnung ob er
wirklich betet er sieht so aus er wusste das war überlegen ich war erstens auf den stühlen
und damit der naggische fuß und dann auch stinge fuß der tipp ist ein Swimport alter
das wäre echt eklig das hat übelst gestunken hast glück dass keine pompe in seinem korb
war annele nee der tipp der war so fertig in eindruck gemacht der hat sich wahrscheinlich
schon lange davor in die luft gesprengt der wäre so gar nicht so weit gekommen xfps hand
reveal sieht man meine hand ja man sieht meine hand ja hand hand reveal hand reveal
alter hand reveal sind das nicht diese weiber schuhe die alle im winter tragen psychologik
sei aber du weißt wenn ich meine wahrscheinlich ich glaube nicht dass der typ so viel kohle
hat der hat bestimmt irgendwo einfach schuhe mitgenommen entweder geklaut oder mitgenommen
die rufstatt wir machen morgen weiter was wir lernen in der schule zur zeit c++ aber
irgendwie leuchtet mir nicht ein was man damit machen kann ich weiß dass c++ eine mächtige
sprache ist und ich finde sie auch ziemlich interessant aber was kann man als anfänger
projekte machen c++ ist zum einstieg scheiße c++ ist ich weiß dass wenn viele leute jahre
lang c++ machen anders sehen und auf diesem niveau ist die sprache auch nicht schlecht
aber c++ ist keine keine schöne sprache in dem sinn ja es ist so taktisch servier an
vielen stellen es hat viele anlasten dabei und das wird auch kein c++ fern bestreiten
können dass da viele anlasten dabei sind du hast viele konstrukte mit doppelpunkt doppelpunkt
und irgendwie so komisch dinger und c++ leute neigen auch gerne dazu alles abzukürzen also
hübsch ist es nicht dazu kommt dass wenn du nicht aufpasst und c++ nicht richtig modernes
auch ordentliches c++ lernt dir auch relativ schnell selbst in fuß schießen kannst und
auch wirst ja auch das library ecosystem ist in c++ servier prinzipiell muss man sagen
für c++ gibt es natürlich unglaublich viele sachen vor allem alte sachen neue sachen
nicht mehr so richtig zumindest nicht so viel aber selbst da einfach mal in der library
einzubinden ist teilweise schon gar nicht so einfach und vor allem das ganze zu finden
ja gibt ja keine ordentliche paketverwaltung für ja also ich finde c++ zum einstieg scheiße
was man damit machen kann ja gut du kannst ja was was macht man als einsteiger am besten
mit c++ ganz ehrlich da fällt mir jetzt nichts gescheites zu ein du könntest du könntest
du könntest cute lernen das ganz gut wenn es cute guise machen ist für mich das beste
cross platform gui framework origin ist übrigens auch hat auch cute runter ob das jetzt ein
gutes beispiel ist weiß ich nicht gut ist das beste beste gui framework für mich cross
platform wenn ich sogar das beste überhaupt also ich finde an sich ziemlich cool also
qml nicht nicht nicht cute forms oder wie es heißt
sampler beste naja cute ja tatsächlich man spricht man spricht es so aus
aber hier ist wirklich schön lebt auch vieles nervige von c++ ab soll ich irgendwann mal
das meme tool cross platform machen da wird das gui auf jeden fall auch cute cute ist super
also mit direct x zusammen eher weniger mit opengl zusammen ganz gut deswegen ist auch
das erste was man für cute machen muss den also der witz ist ja man kann einstellen dass
cute unter windows mit direct x laufen soll läuft aber kacke wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher
bin ob es nette start x unterstützung hat was besser ist wenn man das muss man sich
mal vorstellen wie fail das eigentlich ist wenn du cute startest und sagt sagt quasi
ja bei deinem konfigurations code sagst du es soll angel verwenden wisst ihr was angel
hieß das engel ich glaube schon wissen dass es das ist eines der abgedrehten sachen ja
wenn du cute mit engel laufen lässt ist das richtig schnell engel ist ein on the fly opengl
zu direkt x übersetzen also sprich cute läuft besser mit unter windows cute läuft selbst
mit direct x unter windows scheiße direkt mit opengl scheiße cute läuft gut unter windows
richtig gut mit opengl zu direct x übersetzer dazwischen da läuft es aus irgendwelchen
gründen gut keine ahnung warum und dann am besten auch nur direct x 9 aber so ist das
halt mit cross platform zeug da hast du dich halt musst du dich halt oft mit dinge rumschlagen
die du mit der jeweiligen technologie die auf der platform zu hause ist nicht machen
musst c++ ist der cute creator ist auch der cute creator ist auch die beste freie c++
ide finde ich den kannst du auf jeden fall verwenden für c++ der cute creator ist wirklich
gut aber stehen sie nicht sogar drauf ich hatte ihn zumindest mal drauf
oder einfach elektronen so ist es oder aber in zukunft vielleicht flatter aber aktuell
ist es so dass es neben cute keine ernst zu nehmende native cross platform technology
gibt gibt es nicht gtk kannst du komplett in die tonne kloppen was das angeht also das
ist linux gnome fertig aus mehr nicht wenn es ein bisschen aufgeblasener sein darf und
ein bisschen mehr hipster und neuer dann elektron oder aber vielleicht wirklich demnächst flatter
vlc med vlc ist beste alternativ auch m player vlc ist das beste
ok also wisst ihr was ich hol mir noch mal kurz was zu trinken und dann schwätzen wir
noch mal wir können auch wir können auch 15 min namens 23 uhr dann ich bin müde ganzen
tag broggers schlaucht er also wenn ihr noch was wissen wollt oder noch irgendwelche themen
habt schreibt es in chat ich gucke es mir gleich ein schon mal noch kurz was zu trinken
am übel trockenen halt
nice
So!
Ups falscher Knopf
So, gibt's noch irgendwas? Musst du am Wochenende arbeiten? Nein, muss ich nicht. Und auch am
Montag nicht. Das ist was sehr, sehr nice ist. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie ich es ausgehalten
habe, früher überhaupt 5 Tage in der Woche zu arbeiten. Stuhlmogger, ja, du kannst ja mal
in die History gucken. Ich habe relativ viele Programmier-Streams gemacht, auch in der Vergangenheit.
Kannst du auch beim Archiv, beim Sebaro gucken, im Archiv. Ich habe eigentlich so die letzten
Monate eher so 50-50 Gaming und Programmieren gemacht und letzter Zeit eigentlich hauptsächlich
programmieren, weil es keine Games gibt, die mir gefallen. Oh, Mods sind wieder da. Köpfe einziehen.
Hat sich seit dem letzten Serverraumvideo was an deinem Setup geändert? Noch nicht. Läuft
noch alles so, wie ich es da gezeigt habe. Sieht auch ziemlich genauso aus. Aber ich
werde am nächsten bisschen umbauen. Der Server kommt wahrscheinlich weg, weil mir das ein
bisschen zu viel Single-Point-O-Failure ist. Der macht ja alles. Von TV-Aufnahme bis NAS,
bis Internet-Router, der macht ja alles. Das ist der Server, die 4AE-Kiste. Ich habe mir
so einen Mikrotik-Router gekauft, der macht dann Internet-Gedöns und VLANs und du hast
ja nicht gesehen, was jetzt die OpenSense-VM auf der Kiste macht. Das wird auch eine extra
Kiste. Heim-Automatisierung und TV-Aufnahme wird auch eine extra Kiste. Aber ein Low-Power-Stromverbrauch
sparen. Ich hoffe, dass ich dann so ungefähr auf die Hälfte vom Verbrauch komme, wie es
jetzt ist. Aktuell braucht das komplette Rack komplett. Mit USB, mit Server, mit Switchen,
mit Unity-Media-Moder, mit Fritzbox für die Telekom. Auch mit dem 10 Gigabit-Switch braucht
das ungefähr 100 Watt idle. Das ist nicht viel. Wer schon mal vor einem ordentlichen
Rack gestanden hat, wird sich kaputtlachen bei dem Teil, was ich hier stehen habe. Das
ist nicht viel, aber trotzdem 100 Watt sind 100 Watt, die einfach nur da sind. Und fragt
mir jetzt bitte nicht an mit Watt pro Sekunde. Da hatte ich letztens erst wieder eine Riesendiskussion
geplaudet, die haben da kein Verständnis für, dass es nicht pro Sekunde ist, sondern
dass es schon eine Einheit ist, die quasi Energie pro Sekunde ist. Dann nochmal pro
Sekunde. Egal. Anderes Thema. VS Code oder Sublime Text? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Früher hätte ich immer gesagt... Also eigentlich, wenn es rein ums Editieren geht, würde ich
sagen Wim. Ich hätte auch lange Zeit gesagt, wenn es um Editieren plus Extrawurst geht,
Emacs. Allerdings ist die Emacs-Community mittlerweile deutlich langsamer als die anderen
Communities, was neue Sachen angeht und was Weiterentwickeln angeht und was wichtige Features
angeht. So blöd es sich jetzt anhört, es kann nicht sein, dass ein Editor 2019 immer
noch keine Emojis kann. So doof das klingt, das braucht man eigentlich nicht, aber das
ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, rein Editor, wenn man sonst
nichts anderes außer editieren möchte, was eigentlich der häufigste Fall ist, wenn du
auf dem Linux-System unterwegs bist, willst du einfach nur schnell was editieren und brauchst
keine großartigen zusätzlichen Dinger, dann würde ich sagen Wim. Ansonsten muss ich
sagen mittlerweile Visual Studio Code. Früher hätte ich gesagt Sublime Text. Visual Studio
Code ist schnell genug, es kommt natürlich an den Speed nicht an Sublime Text ran, ich
bin ansatzweise. Aber Visual Studio Code ist schnell genug und hat halt den Vorteil von
dem saumäßig aktiven Plugin Ökosystem. Allein schon dieser Livesurfer ist Gold wert,
mit dem wir immer die Seitenpreviewed haben. Was machen die Aktbilder auf dem Dachboden?
Jetzt hast du schön ausgedrückt, dass du Aktbilder anstatt Nacktbilder geschrieben hast.
Die sind nicht mehr auf dem Dachboden, die sind doch, die sind wieder auf dem Dachboden.
Die waren erst im Schuppen neben dran und jetzt sind sie wieder auf dem Dachboden, weil
es da reingeregnet hat und ich wollte, dass die Bilder kaputt gehen. Was ist eigentlich
aus dem Freitag frei für YouTube geworden? Mach ich doch, bloß dass es Montag ist. Hast
du eigentlich mal wieder Battlefield 5 gespielt? Ja, habe ich, aber das ist nicht mein Gamer.
Den Server noch nicht ins Rack eingeklidert, nur das steht immer noch oben drauf. Es hat
ja auch damals einer geschrieben unter einem Video, dass keiner allzu gute Idee ist, den
ins Rack zu stöpseln und da habe ich mir gedacht, der hat eigentlich recht. Plinkt
dein Klo noch? Nein, das plinkt nicht mehr. Da habe ich die Filter gewechselt. Dass der
Hersteller für mein Klo eine Brandwarnung rausgegeben hat, habe ich euch erzählt,
oder? Hast du nur eine 32 Stunden Arbeitswoche? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel es ist, ich glaube
sogar noch ein minimal weniger. Es waren nämlich vorher auch schon keine 40. So, 37,59, ganz
komisch war das. Also kein 10 Gigabit mehr. Ja, den 10 Gigabit Switch werde ich wahrscheinlich
behalten. Den kann ich auch schlecht verkaufen, weil ich habe Custom Lüfter drin und ein
bisschen umgebaut. Wie backups du deine Daten mit Borg-Backup?
Welche Programmiersprachen beherrschst du? Das müsste man eigentlich auch mal als Command
im Chat machen, weil das wird fast jedes Spiel mehrfach gefragt und ich muss mir immer übelst
in mich gehen, dass ich nichts vergesse. Also fangen wir mal an. C Sharp, Ruby, Python, halbwegs,
ich kann nicht mal denken. Keine Ahnung, 6, 7 Stück oder so. Bash, Groovy, Airwa Skript.
Ich habe bestimmt auch das eine oder andere vergessen, aber ich kann echt nicht mehr
nachdenken gerade. Ja, Qt mit C++ kriege ich auch noch gebacken. PHP kriege ich auch noch
hin, wenn es sein muss. PowerShell, das zähle ich mal nicht auf. SQL kriege ich auch noch
hin, weil das kann man nicht wirklich als Programmiersprache durchgehen lassen.
Akronis zackt, Sibaro. Also okay, für Windows vielleicht. Aber ansonsten nehme ich nur Borg-Backup.
Wie wichtig ist eigentlich Mathe beim Programmieren? Das kommt ganz drauf an, was du machen willst.
Das kommt wirklich ganz drauf an, was du machen willst in welchem Bereich. Jetzt hier bei dem
Zeug, was wir hier machen, so ein bisschen Web-Kram und das ist gar nicht. Wenn du da
irgendwie bei Machine Learning dabei bist, dann sieht das schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Oder auch bei 3D-Geschichten. Was erzählen die Klo-Geschichte nochmal? Ach so, die,
da das brennen kann. Der Hersteller hat Bescheid gesagt, dass das Klo anfangen kann Feuer zu
anfangen. Das hier. Habs da nicht noch ein Pro oder so? Das da, genau. Man sieht es
irgendwo. Man sieht es nicht. Also hier neben, das ist das Richtige eigentlich. Hier neben
ist so ein, nicht der Aufsatz. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das das 9000 da war. Ich hatte doch
mal irgendwo ein Video gemacht. 8000 plus. 8000 plus. Ja genau, hier sieht man es gut.
Hier neben kann man aufmachen und da ist Technikzeug drin. Hier ist die Fernbedienung drin. Da
ist Technikzeug drin und es war wohl so, dass ein Bauteil, was die Spülflüssigkeit zum
Schläuche reinigen intern verteilt, das war porös und deswegen konnte quasi entzündbare
Reinigungsflüssigkeit auslaufen und hier neben reintropfen und hier ist ja unten dann
auch noch Lüfter, Heizung und sonst was und dann da reinlaufen und sich entzünden
und das Klo konnte dir abfackeln. Ja, das war das Problem da dran. Da du gerade so gerne
Fragen beantwortest, in letzter Zeit schon mal Wine plus DXVK beziehungsweise Proton
getestet. Nein, habe ich noch nicht. Soll aber gar nicht so übel sein. Hast du schon
mal Groovy Pipeline Skript mit Jenkins gemacht? Nein, habe ich nicht. Für Jenkins gemacht?
Nein, habe ich nicht. Wir haben echt einen Command fürs Klo, geil. Hast du jetzt ein
anderes Klo? Nee. Da kam ein Typ vom Hersteller und hat es repariert. Nachdem ich auf Twitter
swollen musste, Mari pro 95 es ist schwierig Informatik zu zestudieren ohne Programmierung
zu lernen flashing, irgendwelche Tipps Ja Vorsicht, das ist eigentlich richtig einfach.
nicht programmieren lernen zu wollen, sondern quasi was bestimmtes machen zu wollen, wozu
man programmieren können muss, falls man das jetzt verstanden hat.
Na also ich meine, wenn du sagst, du machst Richtung Telekommunikation, du könntest zum
Beispiel mal einen Wolb klein selbst basteln, natürlich nicht komplett selbst basteln,
schon ein paar, weil das alles selbst basteln ist natürlich bei Zip und bei Wolbs viel zu
übertrieben.
Aber sowas könnte man ja mal machen und wenn du sagst, hey das ist was, was dich interessieren
würde, dann suchst du dir die passende Technologie aus, mit der man das machen könnte.
Wenn man damit rangeht und sagt, ich hab keinen Bock auf programmieren und muss programmieren
dann ist schlecht, es ist immer besser, wenn man sich überlegt, was könnte man dann cooles
machen und sich dann das passende dazu raussucht, was man dazu braucht ist zu machen.
Ganz ehrlich, hast du die Arschdusche vom Klo mal benutzt?
Klar immer, das Beste, du kannst sogar heizen.
Guck da, da sieht man es, das kommt dann hier rausgefahren und sprüht dir warmes Wasser
an den Hintern.
Da hier, da sieht man es doch gut, das ist super, viel angenehmer als mit Klopapier,
natürlich brauchst du immer noch Klopapier, musst einmal noch trocken machen danach,
aber ansonsten, also was ich nicht verwende ist den Föhn, den Föhn verwende ich nicht,
es hat ja hier, hier neben ist ein Föhn und hier ist Wasser, aber den Föhn verwende ich
nicht, nur das Wasser und dann ist Klopapier trocken und gut ist.
Kann das Klo auch das Verhalten des Benutzers auswerten, habe ich noch nichts zugefunden,
ja und eine serielle Schnittstelle könnte es haben, auf der anderen Seite sind ein paar
Anschlüsse, es könnte eine serielle Schnittstelle haben, so, den könnte man mal hausten, ich
habe in letzter Zeit keine Leute mehr gehostet, weil ich keine gefunden habe, zum hausten
haben wir irgendwas, weil ich folge eigentlich fast nur englischsprachigen Channels, ich
würde ganz gerne ein paar deutschsprachige hosten, aber da kenne ich keine, oder halt
wie was kleines, es bringt jetzt nichts, wenn ich irgendwie Dance Gaming oder Kronk hoste,
wenn das serielle Schnittstelle kann, kann das sogar Internet of Things, bezüglich Heimautomatisierung
und Internet of Things bin ich gerade dran, dass meine Türklingel intelligent wird, aber
dazu muss erst noch die Kamera kommen, die ich mir bestellt habe, eine Vandalismus geschützte
gegen Sprechanlagenkamera, der Krieger ist gerade auch noch, wie viele Leute gucken eigentlich
beim Krieger auf Twitch zu, wann spielt er denn, Casino, also ich weiß, das ist ja quasi
sein Ding so, aber Casino, Casino Streams haust ich nicht, ich finde das ist sowas, das mag
ich auf Stream nicht, Glücksspielzeug muss es meiner Meinung nach nicht auf Twitch geben,
Glücks HD, wer weiß was da draufläuft, Linux wahrscheinlich, dann wird da wahrscheinlich
auch Docker drauflaufen, gab es da nicht das Montana Black Drama, ich habe keine Ahnung,
ich verfolge das überhaupt nicht, ich verfolge das überhaupt nicht mehr, ich gucke auch
kein deutschsprachiges YouTube mehr oder sonst was, also kannst du folgen, was, wen
soll ich hausten, ich bin übelst kaputt, ja das ist aber englischsprachiges, ich würde
gerne mal ein deutschsprachiges hausten, also ich weiß echt nicht, wer ich hausten
will, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst
kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin
übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt,
ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt, ich bin übelst kaputt,
ist das Tio? sieht übelst aus wie Tio
ne doch nicht
doch der sieht Tio schon ein bisschen ähnlich
was haben wir sonst noch auf Deutsch? Kategorien, Filter
wie kann man programmieren lernen effektiv
warst du gerade weg? ich hab doch dein Zeug schon komplett beantwortet
ich weiß nicht, irgendwie ist da ein paar Hotte Gamer Grills die wir hosten können
keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht wen ich hosten soll
Ah, Weep Zeug
in eins deutschen gibt es der WPF Twitch Chat LED Controller programmiert
ihn hier, oh das sieht jetzt wahnsinnig aus
das sieht auf jeden Fall nicht so billig aus wie mein Webfrontend
ich bin gar nicht eingeloggt
ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen, morgen machen wir das
Tool für Hardware Rad fertig, da fehlt dann immer viel
aber schick
ne die Version schreibt man nicht, gefällt mir nicht
oh die wollen es aber, oh das Trommel Grill
das Original ist aber noch am besten
also Leute, machts gut, wir sehen uns morgen
bis denn, C.O.